in the mid-1980s a philosopher and
theologian by the name of Dr James karst
to find these two types of games finite
games and infinite games a finite game
is defined as known players fixed rules
and an agreed upon objective football
baseball there's always a beginning
middle and an end and if there is a
winner then necessarily there have to be
losers then you have infinite games
infinite games are defined as known and
unknown players which means you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are and new players can join at
any time the rules are changeable which
means every player can play however they
want and the objective is to perpetuate
the game to stay in the game as long as
possible we are players in infinite
games every day of Our Lives whether we
know it or not there's no such thing as
winning education you can come in first
for the finite amount of time you're at
school where we agree upon the time
frame and the metrics grades but nobody
wins education nobody wins health care
nobody wins global politics and there's
definitely no such thing as winning
business
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggled to stay afloat I
quit I'm a business partner and the
thing that kept me motivated kept me
going was studying the stories of famous
successful entrepreneurs and in their
stories it gave me the hope the drive
the ambition the thinking that maybe I
can do it too that extra bit of belief
and I still need their stories today and
I'm honored to share them with you here
as well so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Simon steinek enjoy
but if we listen to the language of so
many leaders it becomes abundantly clear
that they don't actually know the game
that they're playing in they talk about
being number one or being the best or
beating their competition oh we said
that too yeah
oops okay but the question is the
question is
the question is based on what based upon
what agreed upon objectives metrics and
time frames clearly
your competitors the other players in
the game haven't agreed to your metrics
time frames uh or you know or objectives
nobody's agreed what winning looks like
you know and so this is a problem
because when we play with a finite
mindset in an infinite game when we play
to win in a game that has no Finish Line
there are some very predictable and
consistent outcomes the big ones are the
decline of trust the decline of
cooperation and actually the decline of
innovation
and so there's a great irony
in companies that are trying to reinvent
themselves and stay ahead of the curve
while Simon simultaneously trying to
beat their competition and win and be
the best those two are incongruent right
um uh I'll give you an example a silly
example
um when Circuit City went bankrupt Best
Buy didn't win anything
right it didn't win anything there's
nothing their number one competitor fell
out of the game because they ran out of
the will and resources to play but Best
Buy didn't win anything they had to keep
playing in fact with the rise of Amazon
the entire rules of how they played the
game had to change and so the reality is
is when you play with an infinite
mindset you play Not To Beat anyone but
ultimately you play uh the only true
competitor is yourself which is how do
we make our products better this year
than what they were last year how do we
make our services better this year than
they were last year how do we make our
culture stronger this year than it was
last year and it's a game of constant
constant Improvement but there's no such
thing as winning if we don't have a
sense of purpose then you're doing the
thing you're doing just for the sake of
doing it right like I'm making money
just for the sake of money I'm I'm I'm
I'm doing I'm turning this wrench just
for the sake of turning this wrench and
when when we when we do things that
contribute to something else contribute
to something bigger it gives our lives
and our work meaning and when we have a
sense of meaning when we have a sense of
purpose it does many many things to us
it builds our self-confidence it makes
us better decision makers it makes us
better in relationships and at the end
of the day it makes us enjoy our lives
and find fulfillment in my work in in
our work
um and I think so often
um you know and I think there's a a lot
of a lot of people don't think about it
this way way they don't think about
what's the purpose of all of this what's
the reason I'm doing all of this we
usually default to I got to pay my bills
that's a function you know
um because I was told to do it because
everybody has to work or because I'm
just trying to I want to make this
company the biggest or the best
to what end so what to what value
um and so to truly understand purpose
um I think like I said it sort of just
just has positive effects all over the
place what is that Optimist mindset
means
so I think there's a great
misunderstanding of what optimism and
what an optimist is
um you know I think people think
optimism and blind positivity are the
same thing and they're not blind
positivity everything's good
everything's fine everything's good
which a lot of leaders think they have
to do they think they have to be
positive all the time to keep their team
motivated inspired and the reality is it
actually backfires because when we're
going through stress
we actually and we see our leader always
positive always positive we think
there's something wrong with us it
actually backfires optimism is different
um optimism is not naive optimism is
very realistic of optimism is the
undying belief that the future is bright
and we can be in a dark tunnel and say
these are hard times and I do not know
how long we will be here but I do not
know how far away that light is but I
know that if we work together we will
come out of this better than we went in
optimism again is about the future but
it is it is absolutely accepting of
difficulty and stress in the current day
there's a great story of two two
Lumberjacks where every morning they
start chopping wood at the same time and
every day they stop chopping wood at the
same time and every day one of The
Lumberjacks disappears for about an hour
in the middle of the day and every day
he chops more wood than the other guy
and this goes on for months and
eventually the one who works all day
says I don't understand every day we
start at the same time every day we stop
at the same time every day you disappear
for about an hour in the middle of the
day and every day you Chuck more wood
than me where do you go for that hour
and the other Lumberjack looks up and
goes oh we'll go home and sharpen my ax
you know that that if you if you take an
infinite mindset it's not about how much
you can get done each day it's how much
you can get done over the course of a
career over the course of a lifetime and
and you you got to take vacations which
means you turn off your email and you
turn off your phone and you do not
connect to the office you know go
sharpen your ax like you do you take a
Friday afternoon off you know we have
something called duvet days in in our
company where uh um where it's you wake
up in the morning and you just can't do
it and it's not like asking you know
it's not like vacation days where you
plan ahead and it's not like sick days
you know where you're you're actually
sick like you're not sick you just
you just don't want to do it or I'm just
not feeling it today I'm just not
feeling it and you just you can do it
and you do responsibly you can't leave
your team in the Lurch obviously you
know we you have to exercise
um responsible freedom but we give
people an opportunity instead of lying
and pretending that they have a stomach
bug
um because they just can't face the day
that they can just call up and say I'm
I'm taking a duvet day and everybody
goes go go we got you you know go also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there I can tell you what I went through
which is what set me on the journey
um to sharing the message of the why and
and uh helping people find theirs
um a why is like a is like a it's like a
compass Direction it tells you where
you're going
um we can live our lives by accident
which is kind of like getting in a ship
and just sailing or getting in a car and
just driving you'll absolutely see some
amazing things you'll stumble and upon
some amazing experiences but you don't
really have a sense of where you're
going any sort of Direction in other
words what's it all for what the why
does is it provides a path it provides a
map or a compass so you will still have
some of those amazing experiences but
now they have value and worth and
they're taking you towards something
else it's a journey towards something
when I learned my why
um I had this tremendous calm come over
me a sense of my confidence grew
um a sense that my life had more meaning
than I thought it had before and I had
now the choice
um new way of viewing decisions a filter
through which to make decisions which
now I would ask myself does this help
Advance my why or not does this help me
stay on the path that I'm supposed to be
on or is this going to be a random a
random Adventure so the Y provides Focus
Direction meaning and and confidence we
already talked about great leaders or
students of leadership you know how is
your how's your how's your journey you
know do you watch the talks read the
books all the things like that who's
your leadership buddy somebody who who
sort of willing to call you out when
something goes goes a little bit rare
they disagree how'd I do today was that
okay you know to have a an objective
Outsider having a leadership buddy is
really important or a group of folks
that you talked on a regular basis about
it that's huge I have a group of people
that I talked on a regular basis where
we just call each other and talk about
this stuff or tell each other things
that go right and things that go wrong
the stuff that I've learned just from
them telling me stuff huge
um empathy practicing that empathy
muscle is a big one right I said it
multiple times before which is trying
very very hard to replace judgment with
curios curiosity catching yourself where
you're immediately like they're an idiot
they screwed up they got it wrong right
to
I wonder what else is going on or I
wonder what happened or let me go on a
fact-finding mission before I come to a
conclusion right those are things that
are they're they're they're they're
simple but they're hard but you can do
it tomorrow the other big one is
checking in with your folks like having
one-on-ones and just being like how are
you like tell me what's going on like
what's going on in your life you know
and I know especially in a paramilitary
organization my chismo guns you know all
of this kind of stuff but to to have
conversations that are a little bit raw
a little bit vulnerable you know like
people have challenges in their lives
they've got kids who are struggling
through covid they've got family who's
sick like all of this stuff comes to
work you know and having safe spaces and
just checking in with people one of the
best Chiefs that I know every year he
does a listening tour of his whole
organization you could just do it for
your team because hour-long one-on-one
conversations just to listen not solve
anything what can you know how is it
going how's you how's the job what can
we do better and he just listens and
it's this hugely cathartic experience
but he gets tremendous amounts of
learning about what he can do better and
what the organization can do better and
just knowing his people like the names
of their spouses the name of their kids
things like that make people feel seen
and heard you could do that tomorrow
when we feel safe amongst our own the
natural reaction is trust and
cooperation
when we do not feel safe amongst our own
the natural reaction is cynicism
paranoia and self-interest
so the question is how do you create a
circle of safety as it turns out the
human body is built the exact same way
as any organization if we want to direct
the behavior of people inside our
organization what do we do we develop
all sorts of incentive systems we give
them a Target we give them a goal we
offer some sort of bonus and what do
people do they work towards the goals
that we set we direct their behavior it
works perfectly effectively it's worked
the same way with children we give them
gold stars and we get them to do the
things that we want it works perfectly
fine inside the human body are certain
incentives that work exactly the same
way
and if you've ever had a feeling of
Pride status accomplishment love trust
friendship loyalty all of these feelings
that I'll generically call happiness
are basically produced by four chemicals
inside our bodies
they are
endorphins dopamine
serotonin and oxytocin edso
every single feeling that we basically
know is happiness is controlled by these
four chemicals and what they're trying
to do is incentivize us to get us to
repeat behaviors at an hour that are in
our best interest in other words to get
us to cooperate to get us to trust it is
our natural disposition to want to trust
and cooperate and we're always looking
for it which is why this sense of
belonging is so powerful we're always
seeking out people who are like us
we want to be next to people who are
like us call your friends you love
the ones who you know that if you call
them at three o'clock in the morning
they would answer the phone and if they
called you at three o'clock in the
morning you would be there for them do
not do this with family do not do this
with siblings do not do this with your
spouse it doesn't work those
relationships are too close do it with
the friends you love and ask them the
simple question
why are we friends
and they're going to look at you like
you're crazy
because the part of the brain that
controls feelings and behavior doesn't
control language in other words it's
hard to put into words ironically you
stop asking the question why because the
question why is an emotional question
and it elicits emotional responses like
you ask your kids why are you home late
shut up Dad but if you say what were you
doing that you're home late I'll answer
the question right so you after your
friends say I don't why are you asking
me this you switch to what questions
come on what is it about me what
specifically is it about me that I know
that you would be there for me no matter
what
and they're going to hem and Han it's
going to be very difficult for them and
they're going to struggle don't help
them don't let anybody else help them
you have to let them go through the
uncomfortable process and you have to
play Devil's Advocate so they'll say
things like I don't know
you're funny you're smart I can rely on
you and you say good that's the
definition of a friend you have that
with all your friends what specific
specifically is it about me that I know
you would be there for me no matter what
and they're going to go through this
process of and you're going to say good
that's the definition of a close friend
what you're going to keep keep at them
and eventually they'll give up
eventually they'll give up and they'll
stop describing you and they'll start
describing themselves and this is what
my friend said to me they said I don't
know Simon all I know is that I can just
sit in a room with you I don't even have
to talk to you and I feel inspired and I
got goosebumps in fact I'm getting them
right now
right so what they did is they
articulated my value in their lives and
I had an emotional response so you'll
get to the point where they'll say
something that you will either get
goosebumps or you're well up with tears
or something will happen you will have
an emotional response that's the part of
the brain the Olympic brain that
controls those emotions
you won't get the exact words of your
why but you'll get in the ballpark and
my friends what you'll find is if you do
it with multiple friends you'll get very
similar if not the exact same answer
because the value you have in their
lives is the same it's you
so that's a fun way to find your why I
think people make
they create a dichotomy a false
dichotomy that they have to either
choose service or individual success
right that those two are somehow
mutually exclusive
um and that service means uh living a a
life of suffering
um right which is nonsense
um and and then you hear these silly
these silly uh um sort of uh uh
projections like I'm gonna do well so
that I can do good so I'm gonna put
myself first
and then eventually I'll do good for
others you know a a friend of mine who's
a a philanthropist someone came to him
for advice on philanthropy and this was
a former CEO of a very large company
and um
um and my friend asked him so what what
are you most proud of in your
philanthropy and he said well you know
we started this charity in the inner
city where we help kids uh go on to
college and he said that's amazing you
know how many kids have you helped he
said 15 he says is that the proudest
thing you've done you know in your life
he says yeah I'm really proud
and my friend said so let me understand
this you're proud of 15 kids you helped
go to college meanwhile you destroyed
the lies of the 60 000 people who worked
for you you know
um uh like that's that's what happens
when you uh do well so that you can do
good you put yourself at the center of
the equation and then eventually you'll
try and even the the scale so you can
feel good before you die
um
um and the uh and and the reality is the
opposite is true do well uh sorry do
good and you can also do well right
um but doing good should not be
something that we save for our
retirement
um doing good is something that we can
do every day and and and and and it's
remarkably easy I mean what your
neighbor did for you just by looking out
his window was good saying hello asking
somebody how are you and actually caring
about the answer saying please and thank
you you know I mean these are very very
little things that cost nothing that
make other people
um feel like you saw them
that they matter that they're that they
exist
um and that that is that is a that is
all steps we take to to doing good and
of course it can it can it can grow from
there it can scale from there why do you
think start with why that message you
know and the talks around it the the the
idea as well as the book why do you
think that resonated so deeply I think
it's it goes back to being a little kid
right like you tell your kids something
you know whether you're trying to
discipline them you have to do this or
teach them a lesson or teach them values
or explain how the world works you know
and what's the first question they all
ask why
why
because and the worst thing you can say
is because I said so
correct
they want explanation
and I don't think that ever goes away I
think for some reason as adults we just
either stop asking the question out loud
and just accept that for some reason we
have to just do as we're told
um and
um I think that question is an it's an
inherently human question we want to
know why we want to know where we come
from we want to know what our roots are
we want to know why the world works we
want to know why the sun comes up and
the sun goes down you know like we these
are these are not new questions yeah and
and we're we're as a as a species as a
you know we're constantly searching for
re for explanation and the most
confounding things are things that seem
to lack explanation
um then we have debates
we can't just accept you know
um and so uh I I think when when when
you so publicly ask the question why
about a very difficult thing like
why do I do what I do why do I get out
of bed in the morning and why should
anyone care
right I think that pulls on the
heartstrings of pretty much everyone a
finite game is known players fixed rules
and agreed upon objective
football baseball there's always a
beginning middle and an end and if there
is a winner necessarily they have to be
losers then you have infinite games
infinite games are defined as known and
unknown players which means new players
can join anytime and you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are the rules are changeable
which means every player can play
however they want and the objective is
to perpetuate the game to stay in the
game as long as possible companies come
and go and yet the game continues with
you or without you and there's no such
thing as winning nobody wins business it
doesn't exist but if you listen to the
language of too many leaders it becomes
abundantly clear they don't always know
the game they're playing in they talk
about being number one or being the best
or beating their competition
based on what you know and I love it
when Executives come to me and say you
know we are number one and I always say
for now you know
um and so and so
um the idea of building a company that
can survive every single employee in
this room after you've long gone and
that that company remains true to its
purpose
um is a very very powerful thing a great
example is right outside the front door
you know the Walt Disney Company
um you know the purpose that Disney
founded and they've they've gone through
you know trials and tribulations for
sure
um ins and outs but for the most part
you know when they are at their natural
best they are they hearken back to their
founding purpose and I love that I love
that uh you know you ask me is it
essential
I mean depends on what kind of company
you want to run
um if you want a company that that can
continue to innovate and set set the
course for what business should look
like Define what Innovation looks like
in your industry long before you're all
you know long after you're all gone then
build that company but if you want to
build a company that just
um sucks the life out of people who work
there and does damage the in you know to
the industry all the name of it does
damage to the the communities in which
we work all in the name of short-term
gains you can build that company too and
it'll come at a much steeper cost
um in terms of Love loyalty you know
Etc et cetera so when my career was just
getting going
uh and I was a speaker
uh which by the way was not my chosen
career I fell into it
um uh there is a I forgot the name of
the organization I think it's called The
Meeting Planners Association of America
something like that where basically all
the people from all the corporations and
conferences who hire the speakers like
that's their job they have their own
conference
and so to get invited to this thing is
like
it's like American Idol like yeah like
if you do well you get a career for the
rest of your life because everyone in
the room will want to hire you for their
conferences for the rest of years and if
you if you bomb they all know who you
are and you will have no career right
like that's like I've done this a bunch
now I'm you know I'm relaxed on stage
now you know I got this you know and
like this is one of those events that
makes every speaker nervous and uh
and it's in this cavernous Place
ironically it's like the worst venue it
was like it echoed so you'd stand on the
stage talking you could hear yourself
anyway during my talk I'm doing start
with Y is back in the early days
I got this you know
done this a million times and don't know
what happened I lost my train of thought
okay I I know this I've been through
this from before so I went quiet
you usually find my place and then I
pick up again like I know how to do this
I've lost my train of thought before I
went quiet
and nothing happened like nothing came
into my mind I had nothing
and now I panicked
and as soon as the Panic sets in now now
all rational thought disappears and now
I start sweating and my heart starts
pounding and I got nothing I got nothing
and I look at my pad and I look at the
audience and I look at my pad and I look
at the audience
and then I turn to them and say
have you ever had that feeling where you
forget what you're talking about
and everything collapses your hearts and
your stomach your hearts pounding you
start sweating your hands get clammy and
sheer panic and they're all smiling I go
I said I'm having that right now
I said I said and I gotta tell you it
feels fantastic
I said because I do this so much
sometimes I forget to be present and I
said right now I feel completely alive I
said I feel totally present and totally
with this it's as much as I is as crazy
it is this is amazing
I said okay I need someone's help can
somebody please tell me what I was just
talking about because I do not know what
I was talking about and they all erupted
in Applause
I got more Applause for that
than
for the actual speech
but the point is the point is
is that in every so in every cloud there
is a silver lining in everything that
happens to us there is goodness the part
of the maturation of your work
is and a pretty clear the mission of you
know helping people rather than always
you know the over almost the over
consumption of self-help
right so the framework of your own
company just give me a a second on that
and how you're looking to move that
needle
yeah so there's an entire section in the
Bookshop called self-help but there's no
Bookshop there's no section the Bookshop
called help others
um and I think that's the thing we're
missing you know I I think since the
1970s when the self-help industry began
it it's done very well for itself
um uh uh and the question is is it's it
has taught us a skill but it's it's also
teaching us to to be preoccupied with
ourselves
and I think as social animals one of the
things we've forgotten is we also need
to learn to help each other
and if you look at some of the
challenges that plague us today whether
it's disengagement at work or loneliness
at home or struggle to find the job we
love or funding find the relationship
that we love you know uh all of those
things the antidote to all of those
things is another human being
um and the our ability to help somebody
else find the thing that they're looking
for actually is uh actually gives us the
thing we're looking for uh and I'm
living proof of that it's when I learned
when I learned the value of service
everything that I wanted to feel
everything that I wanted to achieve
started to fall in place only when I
learned to to serve others first the
best leader is actually the best
follower is even if they're at the
highest levels of the organization
they're still in service right it may
not be to a person but to a cause an
idea a vision whatever it is there's
still some sort of something that
they're beholden to and they're devoted
to and they're in service to
um so so followership is a thing
um and
um not to belabor the Marine point but
uh you know Marines when they evaluate
their leaders they're looking good for
good leadership and good Fellowship so
for example there when you go through
OCS officer candidates uh School
selection
um uh when somebody's a for a task you
know chosen to be the leader of that
group for that task the the Marines are
watching the others as well so they're
looking to see that everybody's
contributing ideas and they're looking
to see that that leader takes in those
ideas but is decisive and and they're
looking to see that the the members of
the group if their idea isn't picked
they still give their all
to see that that the leader's idea is
successful and if it fails give it their
all to pick up the pieces and see what
they can do as opposed to going I told
you right should have gone my way right
I was right or sabotaging because their
idea didn't get picked so they go all in
so so good followership is is as
important as good leadership that that
we we respect that that
um when a decision is made we will we
will give our Blood Sweat and Tears to
see that the decision our leaders have
made will be successful and if it fails
we will help pick up the pieces because
that's the deal the U.S marine told me
the first Criterion for being a leader
is you have to want to be one
um and if you look at the way the
Marines select their leaders select
their officers it's a it's different
than than with their enlisted core so if
you enlist in the Marine Corps you go to
Paris Island in the East or you go to
San Diego in the west to to boot camp
and they will make you into a marine
that's what it says we make Marines yeah
and uh if you change your mind
you're gonna be in the Marine Corps
whether you like it or not there is no
changing your mind yeah once you sign on
the dotted line you're in yeah in the
office of core it's different if you
want to be an officer in the Marine
Corps you go to OCS and Quantico
Virginia
and uh it's a 10-week training
and uh you only have to stay in the
first four weeks uh for the next six
weeks you can drop out at any time for
any reason yeah
um and the reason is is because if you
don't want to be a leader they don't
want you yeah they give you the choice
um you know leadership to me is like is
like is like being a parent everybody
has the capacity to be a parent doesn't
mean everybody wants to be a parent and
everybody should be a parent right
leadership is the same everybody has the
capacity yeah it doesn't mean everybody
wants it and doesn't mean everybody
should yeah it comes a great personal
sacrifice it means you have to
constantly worry about other people like
being a parent yeah
um you have to uh love them whether you
chose them or not yeah you know yeah uh
your team uh and and there are skills to
being a parent and everyone who's ever
had a child starts reading books when
they find out that they're pregnant for
the first time you know uh they start
asking their friends they start asking
their parents for advice and it's
constant you know whether the kid's
struggling at school or struggling at
home or having a good time there's it's
all the things like I I hate hanging out
with my sister and my brother-in-law
when they're with their their other
friends who have families because all
they talk about is kids yeah right
um uh well leadership's the same yeah
leadership's the same you know the the
great leaders that I know or are all
students of leadership they're obsessed
they're constantly talking about it
they're reading books about it they're
watching talks about it they're reading
articles about it they get together they
it's it's the topic of conversation sure
um and so you know if you want to learn
the skill set I mean number one you have
to want to do it
um and B you're gonna have to do some
work yeah I mean it takes it takes
effort purpose is always idealized right
like as I said before I imagine a world
in which right I know I'm not going to
get there like when Martin Luther King
said I have a dream like one day little
black children will hold hands on the
playground with little white children
right like all of these things they're
all striving
and the the Milestones that we pass make
us feel like we're making progress and
that's why metrics are really important
and Milestones are really important and
the most important thing is context
there's nothing wrong with quarterly
numbers and annual numbers the only
question I would ask is to what end
to what end like you know I was talking
to a young entrepreneur last night
and she's looking for investment and one
of her potential investors said
um how long is it going to take you to
hit a hundred million dollar revenues
and I said don't take that person's
investment
show me one article one I just need one
show me one article on hbr one study I
don't care that demonstrates that hyper
growth or high speed growth is good for
is good for the company on any level
the answer is there are none
the pressure comes from that person
trying to achieve their financial goals
so they put pressure on you to make your
short-term goals right and so
um and so there's nothing wrong with
goals as long as we understand the
context and the purpose of that goal
right I like to think of money like fuel
right and a car is the company and the
purpose is the destination right and if
money is fuel it makes the car go you
absolutely have to money to make the
company go you have to have you have to
there is no dreaming big if you have no
fuel you can have the most beautiful car
in the world
and yet if you've got no fuel it's
pointless but we don't own a car to buy
fuel
right we don't own we don't have
companies simply for the money
right it's the destination you want to
be able to go somewhere and the and the
passengers are the employees and they're
excited not about the fuel in the car
how much fuel do we have no one gets
excited by that
we get excited where we're going
we're going to Alaska are we near and
it's and and that's the analogy and when
there's a roadblock if you're only
driven by by uh the metrics then the way
we think about money the way we think
about corporate goals the same way we
think about our goal is to drive 200
miles a day our goal is to make x amount
of money right that's how we think about
it well what happens if you drive 150
miles
is that a problem what happens if
there's a roadblock
do you know what to do you start
freaking out and panicking because
you're going to miss your numbers we're
Purpose Driven companies that know their
destinations in the idealized state they
take detours and to the outside world
that looks like you're going sideways or
slowly but you know you're just going
around
and that's how companies actually look
you know it's circuitous and messy and
purpose helps us keep focused on the
very far distant future so we know we're
going in the right vector
even if somebody can't tell we're going
the right direction and so people have
to understand the purpose of the goals
you're setting and how they're
contributing to something and start
talking like we an rpnl
I don't have the word profit on my p l
it doesn't exist
on my p l it says freedom
I damn well want more freedom this month
than I had last month
right freedom to say no to things I
don't want to do
freedom to give it away freedom to take
care of my people
I want freedom because profit means
nothing so I'm trying to contextualize
all of these words that have no inherent
inherent magic to them
so yeah think of money like Fuel and
fuel drives your purpose be Purpose
Driven and talk about the place you're
trying to get to and talk about the
world that you imagine
and the damn world better make a lot of
fuel to get there because it's going to
be expensive it's going to take a long
time the question is how do we create an
environment on in which our people can
work at their natural best and that is
the art of leadership it's creating
environment in which relationships can
thrive in which trust can Thrive and we
all know what it feels like to be on a
trusting team right it means that we
feel psychologically safe enough
to raise our hand and say um I made a
mistake
or I need help
or I'm having trouble at home and it's
affecting my work
or I'm scared or I don't know what to do
without any fear of humiliation or
retribution but rather to say these
things with the absolute confidence that
someone on our team will rush to support
us
unfortunately we also all know what it
feels like not to work on a trusting
team where admitting any of those things
could hurt your chances of promotion
could hurt your chances of it you could
be humiliated
and so when we when we work on teams
where leadership is creating an
environment where there's where trust is
a at a premium
we force our people to come to work and
lie hide and fake where they're
pretending that they've made no mistakes
they're lying hiding and faking and
eventually things will crack and things
will eventually break and and when you
talk about reinvention and you talk
about Innovation and you talk about
challenging the status quo or whatever
it is
necessarily there's risk and necessarily
there are mistakes and necessarily
there's stupid ideas and you have to
create an environment which that's good
the alternative is everybody playing it
safe which is not the way that leads to
to best or significant Improvement so
this is this is absolutely essential if
you want to play in the infinite game
because ultimately every single person
here will leave the organization or die
at some point you know uh circle of life
and you'll be replaced by new people and
so the opportunity is to create a
company with vision and teams that can
Thrive and Outlast every single person
here you cannot have Innovation or
progress without failure it doesn't
exist
and if you truly aren't failing as
you're trying to innovate then you're
probably not pushing very hard because
you haven't broken anything you're
taking you're making very very safe
choices we could never put a person on
the moon without a bunch of rockets
blowing up first like of course
um uh um I I met a CFO once I asked him
the priorities at the company and he
said efficiency and Innovation and I
laughed and said well good luck with
that you know Innovation is inherently
inefficient because it requires
experimentation experimentation requires
failure
um much is said about fail fast I
actually don't like the term that we I
think we overuse the term failure
um you know and the problem with the
word failure is it's like the word
cancer it's too broad like if you have
stage four liver cancer or you have a
mild melanoma those things are both
called cancer but they are clearly not
the same thing and the same thing is
when we hear the word failure some
people think failure means
experimentation but a lot of people
think failure means catastrophe and so
when we tell our company failure is good
fail fast that literally scares people
we don't want to fail so I think we need
a new word right we want to avoid
failure failure is catastrophic and it
should be avoided but Falling I think we
should encourage you know when a kid
falls off a bicycle we didn't tell them
they failed we tell them they fell and
what do we tell them get back up and try
again so I don't want to tell people
they failed I want to see people they
fell and I want to encourage them to try
again and you know brush off their knees
so I think we should fall and fall often
and I will judge the quality of
innovation not necessarily
um by if you fell but how quickly you
can pick yourself back up and try again
let's reinforce that point because I
think it's an important one that
fulfillment is a right and not a
privilege and when we go out with our
friends for dinner or when we used to be
able to do that
um uh uh you know you sit around and
somebody says I love my job and
everybody goes oh my God you're so lucky
like they won something that statement
should be the norm not the exception we
should all get to go to dinner and say I
love my job and it's the one person who
says I don't that's that that we can
that we can intervene
um so yeah I believe it is a right and
we have a responsibility ourselves to to
find a a place where we want to work
with the people that we would work with
rather than just taking the biggest
salary
that we have a responsibility to take
care of the people around us and we have
a responsibility to speak up and ask our
our leaders to work with us and create a
place where people want to come to work
where we where there's a safe space for
us to take care of each other and feel
taken care of so there's Mutual
responsibility all around
um so when you say you know how do we do
it well it's it requires constant work
it's like how do you stay healthy well I
can give you a whole list of things you
have to do you have to eat right you
have to nurse your personal
relationships you have to get enough
sleep you have to exercise you have to
meditate you have to be mindful you know
there's a little there's like 30 things
and you can't do all those things well
all the time it's a striving
um and uh and when one's doing well
sometimes one one thing falls off it's a
striving and it's the same the the
pursuit of fulfillment is a striving you
know I I think it's you know this is why
I make the distinction between
fulfillment and happiness you know to
seek happiness is a lot easier because
happiness is fleeting you know you you
you get a new job you're happy you get a
raise you're happy you win a new piece
of business you're happy you're given a
gift you're happy you know somebody says
something nice to you you're happy and
that feeling goes away
no nobody nobody walks around with a
sense of happiness for a job they got
four years ago it's gone
um where fulfillment is different
fulfillment you can feel fulfilled by
your work even if you're not enjoying it
today
um you can feel fulfilled by your work
even if you if you're having a bad a bad
day you know or or one of your
colleagues is grumpy you can still be
fulfilled by the work it's more it's
more uh it's it's more infinite it's
more constant and so
um whereas happiness is you know the
things that lead up to it it sounds more
like an event fulfillment is a striving
it's a lifestyle
um and you do all these things like
having a just cause like building
trusting teams and working to be the
leader you wish you had in other words
you see your life as a life of service
to those around you whether you're in a
company whether you're an employee
whether you're a leader or if you're
just a parent that you see your life in
service you know to your spouse your
partner or your and your kids and indeed
your community what makes a community
highly functional is that we view uh
that every single person within that
Community sees their responsibility to
serve the community rather than standing
around demanding the community does
something for them there's only one
characteristic that I'm comfortable
saying that all leaders must have to
become leaders and that's courage
because leadership is hard
and it often requires sacrifice
and the the con that it will happen that
you will have to put your interests your
Comforts your advantages aside so That
Others May gain
and that's sometimes really hard in fact
standing up for Others May mean that you
might get your head chopped off you know
a leader sometimes loses their job
because they did the right thing
right that comes with a significant risk
the choice to be a leader comes at
significant risk and this is why not
everyone chooses to be a leader
leadership has nothing to do with rank
it has nothing to do with the title you
have on your card leadership is a choice
that's it I know many many people who
sit in the senior echelons of a
corporation and they are not leaders
they are authorities and they have
authority and we do what they say
because they have authority over us but
we would not follow them
I know many people who sit at the bottom
of organizations who have no Authority
but they are absolutely leaders and the
reason they are leaders is because they
have made a choice
they have chosen to look after the
person to the left of them and they have
chosen to look after the person to the
right of them
it doesn't always mean they have to
sacrifice their interests but when it
really counts sometimes they choose to
sacrifice their interests because it's
in the interest of the person to the
left and to the right of them this is
what leadership
is there is another guy who does what I
do he writes books he gives talks Etc
his work is extremely well respected and
and I admire his work as well I happen
to hate him
he's never he's never done anything mean
to me and we've always had a very
quality relationship when we see each
other professionally I have an arbitrary
hatred of it
and as a result of my hatred I'm
extremely competitive with him
I would log on to Amazon on a regular
basis no and check my book rankings and
then immediately check his
and keep in mind I check no one else's
Just the Two of Us
and if he was ahead I was angry and if I
was ahead I was smug
and whenever his name came up in polite
conversation I would see underneath we
were invited to speak together at a
conference where we would be interviewed
together and I don't mean like like
literally we would be on the stage
together and the interviewer thought it
would be fun if we introduced each other
um
um and so I went first
uh and I turned to him and I said
um you make me really insecure
and I said all of your strengths are all
of my weaknesses and whenever your name
comes up I get really uncomfortable
and he looked at me and he said funny I
think the same thing about you
the reason I was so competitive with him
had nothing to do with him it had
everything to do with me because his
weakness is revealed to me because his
strength revealed to me my weaknesses
it's more difficult to take a hard look
at myself and say Here's all the work
you have to do it's much easier and dare
I say more fun to to direct all my
energies at beating him
um that turned out to be an extremely
cathartic experience
um and I learned the value of a worthy
rival
and the funny thing is after that
experience I've never checked mine or
his book wrecking since
I applaud his work celebrate him want
him to do well because it turns out
working together
we actually are stronger
um and I think this is the same Folly in
business right I I like you know which
is we decide who our competitors are
and then we obsess with beating them
like ABC NBC CBS and fox were obsessed
with beating each other and all they did
was look at Nielsen radians every
morning
and then Netflix came up and didn't like
who cares they're all over the world
because they weren't even looking they
weren't even watching because that's the
arbitrariness of if you I remember back
in the early days when I first started
my career I was in the ad business and I
was Junior dog's buddy to the junior
dog's body and
um I was on the
um competitive analysis team and
basically what that meant was we studied
the competition and we put together
decks to the executives of look what the
competition is doing
and we sometimes would hire outside
Consultants to run you know research for
us and if it was too expensive to study
seven of them we'd cut it down to four
which is hilarious if you think about it
so you're making decisions based on four
and ignore anyway you get my point so um
I think the value of the other players
in your industry of the other players in
the game is not to beat them because
there's no such thing as I said before
you know Best Buy didn't win anything
when Circuit City went bankrupt
um but it's to recognize and respect
them there are some players
who do some or many things better than
you maybe they have a better leadership
stronger culture better marketing maybe
their products are better designed who
knows what and instead of trying to beat
them which could mean you choose
underhanded things or just drop your
price
you actually say okay let's make our
product even better they have revealed
our weakness let's Now work on that
because the ultimate the only competitor
in an infinite game is yourself a just
cause is something a lot more idealistic
it's a statement of the world that you
wish that the the way the world you
wished it worked the it's a world that
you imagine like we imagine a world
that's PWC we imagine a world in which
and then we devote our practice we
devote our energy we devote our
resources to advance towards that cause
and we're going to bring our clients
with us the work that we do takes us
closer to that course so I'll give you
an example so my just cause our
organizations just cause we imagine a
world so you can see there's that
Forward Thinking which as an aside which
is why we call it vision is because you
have to be able to see it right so we
imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe wherever they
are and end the day fulfilled by the
work that they do that is our cause that
is a cause so just that we would be
willing to sacrifice in order to advance
closer towards that ideal we will never
get there it is an ideal okay and you
can look at organizations or leaders
that have made profound impact in their
Industries or in the world you'll see
these just causes whether it's all men
are created equal right it's a just
cause imperfect in all in its own way
but you can see a nation striving
um I have a dream literally imagining
that one day little black children will
hold hands on the playground with little
white children imperfect in its own uh
in in reality but you can see a a nation
striving
um when Apple and Steve Jobs used to
talk about empowering individuals to
stand up to Big Brother you can see the
attraction to the personal computer
because it literally gives power to an
individual to compete against a
corporation imperfect but a striving and
all of these things become striving they
become incredibly inspiring for for a
Workforce because they feel like they're
contributing to something bigger than
themselves but when you think about
innovation
if you say provide greater value for our
clients
and it's not wrong I have to stress it's
not wrong
but but
when you say innovate around that The
Innovation tends to be more features and
benefits it tends to be tweaking and
efficiencies when you say be the best I
don't even know how you innovate around
that right you can't say some to say
somebody
you know make innovate so we're better
but when you say innovate a way to
advance this the ideas can come from
anywhere inside the organization and the
ideas tend to be a lot bigger okay so
it's not that those things are wrong
that what I'm what I'm offering are what
a a clearer path to embracing an
infinite mindset okay right it's not
that the other doesn't work it doesn't
have value it just has less value in the
infinite game what is the existential
flexibility was it say to us so
existential flexibility is the capacity
to make 180 degree strategic shift in
order to better Advance your cause
um and uh the there's a I call it a
capacity because you need two things
there's there's two prerequisites before
you can even make an existential Flex
one is you have to have a just cause in
other words you can't change Roots if
you don't know where you're going
fair enough but then you're just going
to always choose the fastest road but
you may not get anywhere
um and the other thing is you have to
have trusting teams because if if you're
going to make a profound shift in the
way the organization functions or what
its strategy is the the metrics are
probably going to go down in the short
term and you're probably going to
increase the level of stress as the
organization changes and so you need
people who go I understand what the
cause is I see why we're doing this and
and I'm and we're gonna I'm I'm gonna
I'm a part of this and they and the and
the team is willing to go through the
shared hardship in order to do the right
thing for the good of the future
um if you don't have the just cause and
you don't have the trusting teams no
amount of vision from uh leadership will
uh that that existential Flex will
probably fail
um uh um but yeah I mean there there's a
lot of things that reveal and I think
unfortunately you're right I think
the church as a as an as an industry if
we can be so base about it sure but the
church is an industry
um uh unfortunately looks a lot like a
lot of other old-fashioned Industries so
why is it that Apple Computers a
computer company disrupted the music
industry by inventing uh by perfecting
the iPod you know uh iTunes iTunes is
really the thing that changes yeah right
so why didn't the music industry invent
that how is it that Netflix a little
startup that came out of nowhere
um dominates television and movies
Blockbuster doesn't exist anymore
they're they're gone why didn't the
television and movie industry invent
Netflix but they're now copying Netflix
and playing catch-up
you know uh uh uh
it's the the disruption comes from
organizations usually outside of your
your purview
um and you see it all over the place
which uh and I think the the the church
as an industry looks a lot like the
music industry the film industry the
music uh you know the the television
Industries uh which is this is the way
we've always done it this is how we got
big this is how we got successful this
is how we spread our message this is how
we know this is what I know how to do
because this is what I've been doing for
10 years 20 years 30 years and so either
I'm afraid to change because
I only know how to do this or uh this
made me successful and yet I cannot
accept what got me here won't get me
there and I also I'm you know the world
around me is changing technology is
changing politics are changing culture
is changing and I can't do what I used
to do like Sears can't keep selling
sending out catalogs it's not the world
we live in anymore they were the most
Innovative company in the world when
that was a thing
and so the question is how do you adapt
for the world that we live in when we
talk about safe we're talking about
psychological that's right yeah
um uh uh and you can be psychologically
safe and still trip over a court that's
right yeah
um uh so it's it's a great story it's um
I I had a business trip to um Las Vegas
a bunch of years ago and the the client
was very generous and put me up at the
Four Seasons
um which is a Lovely Hotel and the
reason it's lovely is not because of the
fancy beds any hotel can buy a fancy bed
it's because of the people who work
there that when you roam the holes
um and somebody says hello you get the
distinct feeling
that they wanted to say hello not that
they were told to say hello
um you know we're highly attuned social
animals we can tell the difference I
mean it's your idea of being the
Nordstroms is like people can tell the
difference whether they're forced to
give good service or they want to give
good service
um anyway they happen to have a coffee
bar at the Four Seasons in Las Vegas and
uh one afternoon I went and bought
myself a cup of coffee and the Barista
working that day was a kid named Noah
Noah was funny and engaging and charming
and I stood there for far too long just
to buy a cup of coffee
um and so as is my nature I asked Noah
do you like your job
and without skipping a beat Noah said I
love my job
now in my line of work that's
significant because like is rational
right I like the people I like the
challenge I get paid well I like my job
love is emotional it's a higher order
connection like do you love your wife I
like her a lot right
it's it's different right it's not the
same right
so Noah said I love my job so
immediately my ears perk up this kid has
an emotional connection to his job so I
followed up and I said can you tell me
specifically what the Four Seasons is
doing that you would say to me you love
your job
and without skipping a beat Noah said
throughout the day managers will walk
past me and ask me if there's anything
that I need to do my job better anything
they can do for me not just my manager
any manager
and then he said I also work at Caesar's
Palace and there the managers walk
around and just catch us when we're
doing things wrong there they're just
trying to drive performance he says
there I just keep my head below the
radar I just want to get through the day
and collect my paycheck and then he said
something magical he said only at the
Four Seasons do I feel I can be myself
so think about that for a second this is
the exact same human being right in two
different jobs and yet our experience of
him will be profoundly different not
because of him but because of the
leadership environment in which he works
in one experience it'll be amazing and
one it'll be terrible right and I think
so often I hear this all the time
leaders ask you know how do I get the
most out of my people well people aren't
a towel you don't ring them out right
how do I get the most out of them it's a
flawed question when it comes to
leadership the question is how do I
create an environment in which my people
can work at their natural best and the
Four Seasons has figured that out right
it's by giving him or agency it's by
giving him control to to do the job that
he wants to do the way he wants to do it
and checking in to make sure that
leadership isn't there to do his job for
him or to overly control but to offer
guidelines but also offer support and
the same goes in any profession you can
take a cop in one agency who will be
high performance being a valuable member
of the team a valuable member of the
community because of the culture you can
change the agency they work for and they
can be a terrible member of the team
because the leadership environment which
they work it's really easy to be honest
just tell the truth
and if you tell the truth on a regular
basis we will say you have integrity
that's all it means these are really
basic concepts so for example if
somebody calls and a secretary picks up
the phone and says
Dave's on the phone and you say tell him
I'm not
you've just sanctioned lying inside your
organization
that's what you've done
you have said that when it suits you
even if these lies are small you may
tell lies that was dishonest
I went to visit Quantico Marine Base
where the Marine Corps chooses selects
their officers
and on the day I was there
true story
I was waiting in a conference room for
the colonel in charge of OCS to come and
give us a briefing on
on on the base about about OCS about the
the selection process and he arrived
late Marines don't ever arrive late and
he showed up late he came in and
apologized he said I'm sorry we've had
an incident with one of our Marines
so I go what happened you know he said
well we're considering throwing him out
of OCS which means throwing him out of
the Marine Corps like I'm thinking what
law did he break what did he do so I
said what did he do
and the colonel said
um he fell asleep on watch
and I said
that's it
he fell asleep on watch in the woods
of Virginia you know I'm like you guys
are tough
he said and then he explained he said no
you don't understand he said when we
asked him about it he denied it when we
asked him about it again he denied it
again and only when we gave him
irrefutable proof did he say quote I
want to take responsibility for my
actions the problem we have he said Is
We believe you take responsibility for
your actions at the time you perform
your actions not at the time you get
caught
we have another Marine who fell asleep
on watch he admitted it he got punished
we have no problem with him
and he went on to explain he says you
have to understand I cannot
put this Marine in a leadership position
where they're responsible for the lives
of other Marines because if they are in
a combat situation and his Marines doubt
for one second that the words coming out
of his mouth are anything but the truth
if they believe for one second that the
words he is speaking are only to make
himself look better or cover his own ass
trust will break down in the whole group
and people will die
now we are not in life and death
situations but the way our minds
interpret information that is given to
us is in terms of life and death this is
why we don't trust politicians
they tell us the things we want to hear
we don't Prima facia disagree with
anything we've been told but we know
that they don't believe the things that
they're saying and so we as human beings
we're very very smart and this is always
ingrained in us we always make sure just
to keep a safe distance from anybody who
we don't believe is honest because if we
were to find ourselves in a life and
death situation with them you know what
I'm gonna if I had to gamble I'm gonna
say won't go with them
when someone is honest they're willing
to tell us good news they're willing to
tell us bad news they're willing to be
upfront with them even if it's news that
we don't want to hear even if it's not
in our interest
we're okay with it we actually trust
them
Hey listen I I got to be honest with you
your performance has been really bad
these days I love this we're supposed to
give sandwiches give them the good news
before you get to the bad news right so
give them something general and generic
that they don't believe anyway hey
you're really smart
and
on this one project that you did that
you really complete like it's really
specific when they give us the negative
right in other words we didn't believe
the positive in the first place we knew
they were just biting their time to get
to the negative
honesty we keep referring to others in
our space as competitors
but the problem with the idea of a
competitor is a competitor someone we
set out to beat
right and so it's setting up the wrong
mindset
rather we want to have Rivals worthy
Rivals Rivals who are worthy of
comparison and their strengths reveal to
us our weaknesses
and by learning our weaknesses we learn
where we can improve because remember
the infinite game ultimately is a game
of constant Improvement there is no
sitting is best there is only better
that's all there ever is
but if you don't know your blind spots
and you don't know where you're weak how
can you improve that is the value of the
other players in your industry that is
the value of the other people on your
own team you can have a worthy rival
that you work with we've all worked with
somebody that we hate
that everybody else likes and they got a
promotion and we were pissed off
right
the odds are really high that they have
some Talent OR ability that is revealing
to us a weakness that we have and it's
so much easier to hate them than to take
a hard look at ourselves in the mirror
and then work on whatever we see right
you don't have to like or agree with
your worthy Rivals but you have to be
grateful for their existence and we have
to work on the things that it reveals
you have to have worthy Rivals and you
get to pick them talk about competition
a little bit because my God
we're we're hyper focused on beating
people on being right on on competition
I'm afraid of it I need to work harder
like on talk about that a little bit how
we can shift that culture
so my my life and my work has been very
much influenced by a philosopher named
Dr James karst who in the mid-1980s uh
defined these two types of games finite
games and infinite games
um a finite game is defined as known
players
fixed rules and an agreed upon objective
football baseball
um there's if there's a winner
necessarily there have to be losers and
there's always a beginning and middle
and end uh to a finite game
uh then you have infinite games infinite
games are defined as known and unknown
players which means you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are and new players can join at
any time
um uh the rules are changeable which
means every player can play however they
want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible so we're players on infinite
games every day of Our Lives whether we
know it or not you know you can't win
education
you can come in first for the finite
amount of time you're at school where we
agree upon the time frames the school
year and the metrics grades but we don't
nobody wins education nobody wants
learning nobody wins health care nobody
wins global politics and nobody wins
business
but when you hear the language of so
many people they talk about being number
one being the best and beating their
competition
based on what based upon what agreed
upon objectives metrics or time frames
and this is a problem
because when we play with a finite
mindset in an infinite game we play to
win in a game that has no Finish Line
there are some very predictable and
consistent outcomes the big ones are the
decline of trust the decline of
cooperation the decline of innovation
and when people become obsessed with
beating their competitors in a game
where there is actually no winner right
you there's no winning career you can
get a promotion sure but there's no
winning career and there's no winning in
business
and so beating your competition is
actually
based on what
based on revenues profit
based on what one year five years ten
years the lifespan of the company like
what what this is it's all nonsense it's
all made up
and so we spend so much time reacting to
what another player has done rather than
focusing on how we can improve
and so one of the things that I've
learned is to completely eliminate this
idea of having competitors
which is I have no competitors in my
space none there are other players who
do what I do
and some of those players do some of the
things that I do better than me and
those players are my worthy Rivals
and it is better to respect and study
your worthy Rivals because their
strengths reveal to you your weaknesses
and if you can have your weaknesses
revealed to you that means you can work
on your weaknesses because ultimately as
individuals as organizations we're in a
state of constant Improvement that's all
we're trying to do is be better today
than we were yesterday be better
tomorrow than we were today that's all
this game is whether it's your life your
relationships your business whatever it
is it's a game of constant Improvement
and so to obsess about beating your
competition actually takes us away from
constant Improvement because it might
make us do something uh short term or it
might make us do something expedient
because it gives us a short-term leg up
or use cheaper ingredients or trick
somebody or you know because it can
drive revenues and all that does is
weaken our own organization that's all
it does that's all it does
and so I don't think of competitors at
all I think of worthy Rivals and by the
way worthy Rivals can change you know I
get to pick who they are and I get to
pick the reasons that they're my worthy
Rivals and I'm in a state of constant
Improvement thanks to them
and sometimes it's something small and
sometimes it's something big
um but I'm grateful to all those who do
similar things to me because it makes me
a better player we have to have trusting
teams
I was on a business trip in
Las Vegas
and they put me up at the Four Seasons
beautiful hotel
and one of the reasons it's a beautiful
hotel is not simply because of the fancy
bed any hotel can buy a fancy bed it's
because of the people who work there
that when they say hello to you you get
the distinct sense that they wanted to
say hello not that they were told to say
hello
we're highly attuned social animals we
can tell the difference
they happen to have a coffee bar in the
lobby
and so one afternoon I went to buy
myself a cup of coffee and the Barista
working that day was a young man named
Noah
Noah was funny he was engaging I enjoyed
buying a cup of coffee from him I stood
there for far too long buying a cup of
coffee just because I enjoyed talking to
Noah so as is my nature I asked Noah do
you like your job
and without skipping a beat Noah says to
me I love my job
now in my line of business that's
significant like is rational I like the
people I like the challenge I get paid
well I like my job love is emotional it
demonstrates an emotional connection to
whatever we're doing do you love your
wife I like her a lot it's a it's a it's
a different standard right
Noah said I love my job so immediately
I'm interested
so I follow up I said to Noah tell me
specifically
what the Four Seasons is doing that you
would say to me you love your job and
again without skipping a beat Noah said
that throughout the day
managers will walk past them and ask
them how he's doing I ask them if
there's anything that he needs to do his
job better
not just his manager any manager
and then he said I also work for a
different Hotel
and there the managers walk past me and
catch me if I'm doing something wrong
there they're always overbearing and
trying to make sure that I make my
numbers he says there I just like to get
through the day keep my head below the
radar and just collect my paycheck he
said only at the Four Seasons do I feel
I can be myself
this is the exact same human being and
yet the level of performance will be
completely different not because of him
but because of the leadership
environment in which he's working I get
this question all the time Simon how do
we get the most out of our people
they're not a towel that we ring them to
see how much we can get out of them the
question is flawed the correct question
is what environment do I have to create
what do I have to do to help my people
work at their natural best that's called
leadership and when we can create a
trusting team
teams in which people feel trusted and
trusting what will happen is it makes
them feel safe enough to raise their
hand and say I made a mistake
or I'm having trouble at home and it's
affecting my work
or you've promoted me to a position that
I don't know what I'm doing and I need
more training
or I need help or I'm scared
if we do not have trusting teams
what we have is a group of people who
show up to to work every single day
lying hiding and faking they hide all of
the mistakes for fear of getting in
trouble
they won't admit that they don't know
what they're doing for fear that they'll
be humiliated
they're certainly not going to say that
they're scared or that they need help
for fear that it will somehow reduce
their value inside the organization and
eventually things will compound and
break you can't incentivize results like
you can't do that you can only
incentivize the behavior that will
achieve a certain result and if it's
only about the short term then guess
what you're going to drive a behavior
that drives short term and so in your
case what are the behaviors that you're
recognizing and rewarding and so if
people are getting bonused only for
hitting numbers
and they're not getting bonus for how
they do business then you're going to
incentivize a certain Behavior so I'll
give you an example
um so young in my career I worked at an
ad agency and I was the junior dogs
buddy to the junior dogs buddy and um it
was traditional for a big new business
pitch that the senior folks would run
the pitch well it happened to be around
Christmas time and all the senior folks
went on vacation and so me and one other
Junior person who were left behind
because we didn't go on vacation we're
told to prepare the War Room which
basically means take a conference room
and fill it up with all the research
Well that took a few hours right but we
still had a week and so she and I
decided to write the whole pitch we went
through all the research and we came up
with a strategy and we wrote the pitch
all the senior leaders came back we
presented our work and they actually
used our strategy in this new business
pitch and we lost the pitch we didn't
win and I got a huge promotion my boss
actually moved me up two levels inside
the company
because he wasn't rewarding my
performance he was awarding and
rewarding my initiative
by by giving me a promotion for taking
the risk to do the extra work guess what
I did after that took more risks and did
more work even if it meant winning or
losing didn't become the primary factor
for me it was the initiative that but
that wasn't because of me and my and my
innate anything that's because that's
the behavior my boss wanted from me
and so I think what happens when we get
big is we we do become too obsessed with
the result and we don't consider the
behavior there are some brilliant people
making big decisions who may have missed
the number
or may have missed the goal but we gave
them nothing
which sends a subconscious message to
the rest of the company which is if you
hit your numbers you'll do well here if
you don't hit your numbers we don't care
how you do it as long as you know so you
get the point so I think I think it
happens big companies need to go back
and reevaluate how they recognize and
reward
um uh and what if you want if you want
risk taking then recognize the people
taking risks even when they fail so you
say I I've met this person that I really
like how do I build trust well you don't
tell them all your secrets on the first
day right we all know that you have to
be vulnerable but but there is there is
a there's a timing you know and it's a
dance and it's and it's giving somebody
a little extra
responsibility and seeing how they do
and if they screw up instead of yelling
at them be like all right try again you
know that we treat mistakes as learning
opportunities rather than you know and a
mistake is only when you keep repeating
the same error and you haven't learned
anything
um
where we practice empathy you build
trust with empathy as well so
um empathy uh in business looks like
this
um here's a traditional
scenario
somebody walks you know picks up the
phone or walks into their office when we
had when we did that
um and says
you know your numbers are down for the
third quarter in a row
um
we've had this conversation before and
if you don't pick up your numbers in the
fourth quarter I don't know what's going
to happen right that's pretty normal
here's empathy injected into that
scenario hey your numbers are down for
the third quarter in a row we've had
this conversation before
um are you okay I'm worried about you
what's going on WOW right where it's
about the person not the performance
and so when again it goes back to that
listening and you you are not listening
until somebody else feels heard
those things you know seeing someone as
human understanding that we all have
stresses and strains and Egos and
insecurities and we bring all of that to
work
and though we still have to be uh
emotionally professional you know you
can't sit in the meeting like this
because you're having a bad day that's
emotionally unprofessional that we still
have to be emotionally professional
um we're still human beings yeah and a
good leader uh recognizes that
and by the way somebody on a team
recognizes that too you don't have to be
a position of authority to be a good
leader you know because those who may be
higher in rank than us are also filled
with insecurity and fear and stress and
strain and ego and all that right and
it's okay to go up the chain of command
and say hey are you okay you know you're
really hard on us in that meeting today
instead of labeling them an [__] be
like are you are you okay you know and
and by the way and that's the dance it's
like any relationship you know it's not
expected for one person in an
interpersonal relationship to to do all
the listening it's a dance and it goes
backwards and forwards and you know you
you you you meet empathy with empathy
and you meet listening with listening
let's be Crystal Clear what a trusting
team is we've all been on one in the
past maybe and I hope you're on one
right now
um we've all been on trusting teams
where we have psychological safety to
say out loud I made a mistake or I need
help or I don't know
or I've got some stuff at home and I'm
struggling and it's affecting my work
product and I need help without any fear
of humiliation retribution and that'll
affect your promotability that's what
being on a trusting team is and that's
what we have to build for the people who
work for us not being on a trusting team
we've also all been there unfortunately
where we're afraid to say I made a
mistake we would never say I don't know
something or don't understand something
we would never ask for help because it's
we're either going to get humiliated
publicly or we're going to affect our
promotability
um and the opportunity to build trusting
teams is what leadership is all about
that's that's where the the strength of
culture comes from
so uh so yeah it's it's it's it's
essential to building any kind of
business short term or long term
um but definitely definitely a long-term
company for sure and all the stuff you
talk about challenging and pushing
boundaries means if you're pushing
boundaries and you're thinking big
you're going to fall a lot it happens
there's no such thing as innovation
without experimentation and
experimentation inherently requires
failure and I think a lot of companies
that are too finite-minded they fear
failure they fear well let me let me
restate I actually don't like the word
failure you know you hear you hear it a
lot which is you know uh we have a fail
fast culture you know I I think the
problem with the word failure is it's
like the word cancer which is there's a
huge difference between stage four liver
cancer and melanoma and a mild melanoma
but they're both called cancer that's
the problem and there are failures which
are minor and overcomeable and there are
failures that are catastrophic but the
problem is they're both called failure I
like the word falling failure we should
work very hard to avoid but Falling we
should encourage because you can get
back up I know of one large gaming
company and I love this
um that they they don't have parties
when they hit their goals they have
parties when they fail they have they
have parties when a game completely is a
complete blowout
because they're trying to acculturize
being comfortable with missing a goal or
or complete abject failure and they have
a party and they have their own
champagne which it has a label on it
um their own label I think it's called
they're called lessons and on the back
of those champagne bottle after the
party they actually write the lessons
they learn from the failure and so it's
a comfortable it's very comfortable it's
a company that's very comfortable with
failing which means they try again very
easily and they're super innovative
so creating a culture where we're
falling is is part of the game right I
think it's wonderful it has to be
celebrated I love it passion is not an
input passion is an output uh passion
um you know we're all passionate we're
just not all passionate for the same
things and we will feel what we call
passion when we are involved in
something that is deeply personal to us
that is helping us Advance some higher
purpose or cause then when we go to work
what we've what we experience is Passion
but if you make us do something that we
feel no personal connection to that is
not as helping Advance any kind of
bigger ideal than what we feel is stress
now passionate people work many hours
they don't come home they miss their
families they take business trips they
they don't sleep and yet it feels worth
it people who are stressed going to
business trips they miss their families
the work long hours they don't sleep but
it doesn't feel worth it passion is an
output not an input
like stress is an output not an input
so you don't you can't do what you're
passionate about you find something you
believe in and what you will experience
is passion
so then it begs the question how do I
find what I believe in right there's a I
think Society especially our society and
especially for a younger generation puts
overwhelming pressure on us to have a
vision
what's your vision or find your bliss of
all of these they're all the same thing
right
and the problem is we're not all
Visionaries it's unfair it's an unfair
standard that's like telling everybody
be to be creative but we're not all
creative where everybody be good at math
but we're not all good at math
we're not all Visionaries only a small
percentage of our population are
actually visionary
you don't have to have a vision you have
to find a vision
right if you hear Martin Luther King say
I have a dream that one day little black
children will hold hands on the
playground with little white children
you go that's what I want
you choose to follow Dr King
when you hear the words of Visionaries
and if they appeal to you in some
visceral level they give you Goosebumps
they make you excited they make you want
to sacrifice be a part of it stand in
line to hear them pay money whatever it
is
follow that make that your vision take
it and say that's my vision too you can
adopt someone else's vision and make it
your own that's what we call a following
is we have taken the visionary's vision
and we have chosen to follow that Vision
ourselves we are followers that's a good
thing there's no difference between the
Visionary and the follower we both see
ourselves in service to something bigger
than ourselves whether you are the
originator of that idea or not is
irrelevant
what it does is fuel passion
what it does is fuel conviction
so we don't have to have a vision but we
do have to find one and so read books
watch TED Talks read articles be in life
watch videos you know go out seek find
listen listen to leaders corporate
political whoever and when something
resonates with you even if you don't
know why
that then you can adopt and you can take
it upon yourself to use your own talents
your own gifts to help Advance whatever
that cause is
right so I have a cause I have a Crystal
Clear Vision of the world I want to live
in I imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe at work and
return home fulfilled at the end of the
day the gift that I have committed to
help advance that cause
is the ability to put some of these
ideas into words that other people can
relate to
you know when you do a jigsaw puzzle the
first thing you do is lean the Box
against the wall
right we all have a piece of the puzzle
to help build this Vision my piece of
the puzzle is I'm the guy that points at
the Box
but I'm not the guy who builds the
business
because there are other people who are
better at that the entrepreneurs and the
Business Leaders I want them to embrace
the same picture on the box
the people who work for companies who
say I want to work for a company that
does that that's their piece the one
who's A Gifted natural leader who cares
we all have at least one friend who for
whatever reason love us and Care us even
when we're horrible people
that that for some reason they still
believe in us and they see the good in
US that's their piece of the puzzle
and so we have to commit our gifts the
reason they call them gifts is because
they're forgiving
that's what gifts are they're forgiving
away if you have a gift it's not
something you take it's something you
give
so I think we have to find a vision and
commit our gifts to help advance that
vision and the great leaders the ones
that can put that Vision into words so
clear
that we can then recite that Vision as
if it were our own I think very often
companies can risk becoming reactive to
things that happen in the marketplace
which make so here's a great example
right let's use a real life example
Blackberry was a really fantastic
company who built a really fantastic
product with a really clear sense of
vision which is we make strong secure
extremely reliable products and if you
remember if you ever had a BlackBerry
you could throw that thing across the
room drop it on the street and it just
didn't break it just kept working it was
the most reliable product on the
marketplace you could type on the full
qwerty keyboard without even looking
down you could send a hole in the email
and governments and big businesses loved
it because it was really secure and
really reliable
then the iPhone showed up and the iPhone
was the new shiny object
and blackberry instead of sticking to
their core and their beliefs became
distracted by the shiny popularity of
the iPhone which is a completely
different animal serving a completely
different audience and they started
trying to copy iPhone so they started
putting apps on their on their
blackberries which what did it do made
it slow and sluggish then they started
coming out with flat screens you're not
going to make a better iPhone than an
iPhone
um and they basically destroyed their
company because they completely went off
the reservation and and abandoned their
fantastic cause there could be two
marketplaces where you have the shiny
object of the iPhone that we use in our
personal lives and our companies prefer
that we use a a Blackberry because it's
reliable it's safe and it's and it's
really really strong
um and we could have had two dominant
players for two dominant reasons like a
PC and a Mac two dominant players with
two dominant reasons for do two
different reasons but they didn't they
got distracted and I can imagine that
their that their business people were
saying you know business is moving at
light speed we have to react
um or we can work to advance our cause
in a different way and not become
distracted and that's part of the hard
thing which is are we stuck in our old
ways or are we actually sticking to our
sticking to our long-term Vision that's
that's part of the the difficulty of
business to know the difference when
covid first showed up
I loved listening to the commentaries
the number of people who said in these
uncertain times
and I would always giggle to myself
because all times are uncertain there's
never been a time in history that wasn't
uncertain
um all that happened was something that
we didn't expect happened suddenly that
reminded us
you know that things are uncertain every
stock market crashed nobody knew that
was going to happen tomorrow it's always
uncertain and this is where a finite
Minds an infinite mindset rather this is
where an infinite mindset could be very
valuable
because players who play with a finite
mindset
fear uncertainty and work hard to avoid
surprise which is why they like short
time frames we like the quarter or most
the year don't talk to me about three
years or five years that that freaks me
out and I like everything to go
according to Bland and be very
predictable and so when something
unexpected happens Panic is their normal
reaction right
when you learn
when we learn to embrace an infinite
mindset
we actually see opportunity in Surprise
and we Embrace uncertainty
so when something unexpected happens
it's still stressful but when something
unexpected happens we go oh I wonder
what we can do with this this is
exciting hey team come here let's talk
about how do we work in these in these
in this environment
and I saw it happen during covet it was
so easy to see
which companies were playing with a
finite mindset in which you're playing
with an infinite mindset because the
finite-minded companies panicked
and went into survival mode and
everything was about themselves how are
we going to survive how are we gonna
make money right whereas the ones with
the infinite mindset went okay
opportunity here what if we were to
start our company from scratch today how
would we do things like what if we
didn't exist yesterday and today was the
first day of work how would we do things
still very stressful but very exciting
and instead of putting themselves at the
center they were very more preoccupied
with the customer people still want what
we have how do we get it to them as
opposed to how can we make money
and so I could tell the difference
immediately and so the more we learned
to embrace an infinite mindset
uncertainty becomes a joy becomes an
opportunity for creativity
and so it's that's one of the huge
benefits is there practical things we
can do to create a culture of seeking
out that feedback and creating a safe
space well the simple answers of course
um the there's no such thing as a single
Silver Bullet It's a combination of
things it's like what's the one thing I
can do to happy have a happy
relationship well I I can't I can tell
you a important thing but I can't tell
you the important thing so it's the same
um and everybody's a little different
you know and each culture is a little
different so there's there's not even a
set list I can get but there's some
things that people can choose from you
know one thing is one of the ways we
create space is how we react right if
someone gives you feedback and you deny
it
well that's a problem
if somebody gives you hard feedback and
you thank them for it
a very different environment it creates
so I I I'll give you two uh examples one
a lesson the other one a practical
example that someone can use so I had
the opportunity to visit the Army
Rangers uh Ranger school in particular
and I where they make they make army
rangers and one of the uh
troubles they had a bunch of years ago
was they had these folks that they
called Spotlight Rangers which was they
were really good at their job like they
were brilliant at all the tasks that
were set to them strong
they're the teachers the instructors
loved them they stood out they were
great they were motivated but as soon as
the spotlight was turned off when the
instructor wasn't there and they were
back at Barracks they were [__] and
the only person who the only people who
knew were their with their friends and
colleagues because the spotlight was
turned off
and so the Army Rangers implemented a
system of peer review in order to
identify Spotlight Rangers and in now by
the way they started this 40 years ago
which I find incredibly Advanced
um but to advance through Ranger school
you need to pass three tests you need
your instructor to say yep you're ready
to go to the next level you need to
physically actually perform all the
tasks required of you and you need to
pass your peer review
um and if you fail any one of those
three you don't make it to the next
level
interesting and so that becomes an
equally weighted component of
advancement in the Army Rangers which is
what kind of team player are you
which I love
so
we implemented a system of 360 review
um
which was sort of a bit of an
amalgamation of things we've taken from
other groups and made our own
where what we what the way it works is
um
do you take the group of people you have
regular interaction with and
you
um
fill out
uh your top three
weaknesses
or the places you believe you need to
grow the most
with a specific example for each so top
three specific weaknesses or places you
need to grow the most and then top three
specific strengths
or the places you believe
three examples of the places you believe
you've grown the most they have to be
specific
not like Oh I'm a much better time
keeper now not that you've got to give
some specific examples
they're collated and distributed amongst
the team
and then you come together as a group
and you take turns
reading them
so first you read your own weaknesses
and then the group has the opportunity
to add to that list
and here's the best part we give a
little speech before the whole exercise
starts that the people who are going to
give you this feedback
really don't want to
it's really uncomfortable for them
it's going to be uh they they would just
rather not do this exercise at all
but they're going to do it because they
want to see you and help you grow
and so what they're giving you is a gift
and so you have to receive it as a gift
which means you say thank you
you don't have to agree with it if you
don't agree with it say thank you and
just dismiss it it's fine
but if it has an emotional impact if it
makes you angry
frustrated
probably true
right and we go around the room and
somebody's tell they every people can
add to this list of these weaknesses in
any way there's no format they can do it
in any way they want and you sit there
and you look them in the eye and you
genuinely say thank you you're not
allowed to say a word except thank you
then you do your strengths and you read
your threat strengths and anyone can add
to the list
and just as you discovered you have
blind spots you didn't know you have you
discovered that you have strength that
you didn't know you had that you're
having a positive impact on the lives of
others that you didn't know you were
and it's a magical experience there's
usually tears at some point because it's
powerful and it's a safe environment
what does it mean to live an infinite
life
clearly our lives are finite we're born
we die but life is infinite
we come we go and the game continues
with us without us which means every
single one of us has the choice of how
we choose to live our lives how we
choose to lead our organizations we can
lead with a finite mindset
try and make more money than our friends
try and get ahead faster than everybody
else try and achieve more power than
anybody else and when we die we take
none of it with us
but the choice to live an infinite life
means we choose to build an organization
that will be better off because we work
there we will leave it in better shape
than we found it
it means to be the kind of friend and
leader to others that they will be
better because we were in their lives it
means we will literally live on Beyond
ourselves
it's just a choice whether we choose to
live with an infinite mindset or a
finite mindset did just walk me through
because I'm actually very curious about
you before you do you know what I mean
like that's what I'm really kind of
curious about so you didn't you were
like disgruntled with your career a
little bit right I wouldn't say
disgruntled I'd fallen out of love yeah
okay I was I had no passion
for my career okay this was a chosen
career like I started my own business in
the category in a profession that I
thought I wanted to spend the rest of my
life in Consulting marketing oh okay you
know and uh and to wake up one morning
with a superficially good life I own my
own business we had amazing clients we
did really good work our clients liked
us and didn't want to do it anymore
right it's kind of distressing because
as I as I said where we started you know
so many of us intertwine our identities
with our work and if I don't like my
work then who am I right and so I went
through that
um which uh was incredibly unfun
um and it was the discovery of this of
this little idea that I called the
Golden Circle you know where we all know
what we do some of us know how we do it
but very few of us know why we do what
we do and I realized I didn't know why I
was doing what I was doing
um and it was uh it was that crisis
that was designed to do nothing more
than help me find my own passion to get
back my my mojo
um that put me in a path that was um
unexpected
um uh my my entire career is an accident
you know amazing um I am living proof
that uh that you couldn't that you don't
have to have a plan right right exactly
and it worked out for you right you have
to have a vision you have to have a
vector you have to have a Direction but
you definitely don't need to know the
individual steps having a sense of
purpose cause or belief for our work is
what gives our work and frankly Our
Lives meaning
um you know when we die nobody wants the
the last balance in their checking
account written on their tombstone
you know uh nobody wants the last title
on their last business card on their
Tombstone we don't that's not how we
want to be remembered we want to be
remembered for the kind of person we
were in the lives of others you know
devoted mother loving father you know
these kinds of things
um and and we want to know that our work
uh had an impact in something bigger
than ourselves it's a very normal human
thing unfortunately a lot of people
don't start to think about things those
things until later in their lives and
I've heard this I usually hear this from
senior Executives believe it or not
where they say you know I've had great
success and I've done all these things
but but I don't want my I don't want my
life to end on this chapter I I would
feel like I've done something wrong you
know and they want to make sure that
they're that they do something
powerful and impactful in the lives of
others that that's how they want to
close the book on their lives what I
love about this young generation is
they're starting to think about those
kinds of things now
um you know it's not unique to a young
generation everybody wants their work to
matter and have meaning I think our
young generation is just more vocal
about it which is wonderful I always
sort of reject the concept of blunt
honesty you know
um you can be honest without being an
ass
um uh you know do I look fat in these
jeans I like the other genes better
that's an honest assessment without
making somebody feel bad uh for example
um and we also have to get good at
evaluating someone's personality some
people are more sensitive than others
and so a good leader is able to adapt
their style and how they uh offer
information so that um sometimes they
have to be a little more polite to some
and they can be a little more blunt with
another because their personalities can
take it
what we want people to do is hear the
feedback hear the input
and it's based on how they receive it
not how we like to give it we have to be
the adaptable ones
um as as as Leaders
um but he he's absolutely right that
good leadership starts with care and I
hear this all the time unfortunately
which is you know as a leader I didn't
get to uh I didn't get to choose my team
so why should I care about them or why
why should I trust them you know they're
not I didn't choose them well you didn't
get to choose your children you love
them
um and this is one of the the the the
risks of leadership you know leaders
have to take the risk to care they have
to take the risk to trust first I've
never in my life heard a great leader
say proved to me why I should trust you
to their team it's the opposite a leader
takes the risk to trust and it's the
team who says prove to us why we should
trust you that's the correct hierarchy
um uh so so yes you don't you do have to
care you want to see you want to see
your people as human beings first
um you know they are not the problem
they may have a problem and inject a
little empathy into the into the
organization this is what what reflects
care so for example I'll give you one
one example
um uh so here's a pretty normal scenario
somebody walks into an office and says
you know your numbers are down for the
third quarter in a row we've had this
conversation before if you don't pick up
your numbers in the fourth quarter I
don't know what's going to happen
empathy uh changes that you walk into
their office and you say your numbers
are down for the third quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before are
you okay what's going on I'm worried
about you that's empathetic that's the
expression of care that we we recognize
that someone may have a problem but they
are not the problem I'll give you a
personal example the person who's who
sold me this property uh it was the
seller's agent oh okay right he was
charming and nice and wonderful and
lovely and helpful and all the things
that I would expect and I warmed up to
him and he was
apparently helping me and then I
remember distinctly at the closing
he sat there with no personality all of
his charm had left
all his friendliness had gone he barely
engaged with me he just wanted to be
there to collect his checks he could get
out of there
and I realized it was all fake it was
all for show it was all to butter me up
so that I would simply sign on the
dotted line and as a result I will never
work with him again as a buyer or a
seller
I'll never list with him ever and I
probably will never work with that
company again because I realized they
just saw me as a number they never saw
me as a person in the first place
he was an old white guy I mean that
should tell you a little bit of
something as well that that sort of
maybe how he was raised in the industry
um and by the way the mortgage broker
was no different you know uh he was
charming and wonderful and lovely and
helped me get a great rate etc etc and
then I remember after I closed he called
me and said congratulations and I said
oh thank you that's so nice of you and
he called me just to congratulate me on
closing on my house and then the first
thing he said to me was and if you know
anybody who's looking for a mortgage I'd
really appreciate the recommendation he
never called me to congratulate me he
called me because he wanted the referral
like give it a breath
you know like call me and congratulate
me in a week later asked me for the
referral and see let me tell you what
sucks about that can I say that what
sucks about that totally is that's
that one person yeah colored your
entirely and but this is finite versus
infinite okay he he could only see the
transaction he could only see get
business get more business get business
get more business what he didn't
understand is he's dealing with a human
being and the more there's a
relationship I will gladly recommend him
I will gladly introduce you to my guy
right
um now I'm completely agnostic because
if you're going to treat me like a
transaction I'm going to treat you like
a transaction if you're gonna treat me
like a transaction I'm going to squeeze
you to get more money out of you I want
a lower rate I'm going to squeeze the
agents but if you treat me like a human
being I'll gladly pay a higher rate
because I want to work with you and
that's what infinite minded players
understand better which you don't have
to be the cheapest you don't have to
have the lowest rate or the lowest price
if you have a great relationship what
does it mean to live an infinite life
clearly our lives are finite we're born
we die we come we go
but life is infinite
The Game of Life will continue with us
or without us
which means every single one of us has a
choice
we don't get to choose the nature of the
game Life is infinite we don't even get
to choose if we want to play in the game
or night once you're born you're in it
foreign
we get one choice
do you want to play with a finite
mindset
or do you want to play with an infinite
to play with a finite mindset means
waking up every day and say I'm going to
be the best I'm going to be better than
everybody else
I'm going to accumulate more power more
responsibility more money whatever it is
whatever whatever your metric is I'm
gonna I'm gonna get more than anybody
else me
and when you die you take none of it
with you
or we can choose to live our lives with
an infinite mindset
which means I'm going to leave this
world the school in better shape than I
found it it means I'm going to devote my
life to see that those around me rise
and we know that we're living with an
infinite mindset because our obsession
is seeing that we have an impact on the
lives of the people around us
we've all had teachers and some of you
are those teachers we're 20 or 30 years
from now I can go to one of your
students and say you're a remarkable
human being you've accomplished so much
in your life how did you become the
person you are today and they will tell
me your name
we all remember the teacher who believed
in us we all remember the teacher who
had our backs we all remember the
teachers saw something in us that nobody
else saw we've forgotten all the others
but we remember those couple
and that's what it means to live with an
infinite mindset it means we divert
ourselves to that mindset for everyone
in our lives that other teachers will
say that about us other principles will
say that about us other students will
say that about us our friends will say
that about us I am who I am today
because of you and I will commit to live
the same life that you taught me how to
live and you will literally live on
beyond your own lifestyle your own
lifetime
that when you're gone others will carry
your work
for you
this is what it means to live an
infinite life and it is just
a choice to me art is like a gift you
know if you have capacity if you have
talent if you have grit and hard work
and you want to produce gifts are
supposed to be given so what's the point
of giving a gift is no one gets it
right what's the point of producing a
symphony if no one gets to hear it so I
think reception is important to to give
the art point
meaning as opposed to pointless you know
otherwise you're just decorating your
home
now we could have a debate whether I'm
receiving it myself
right
um so we could definitely debate that
but but I I I I uh I think it I think
and maybe this is just the Romantic in
me
um it has to be enjoyed and and maybe
one one one person is fine maybe if you
hang it in your own home and it's just
for you that's fine too but uh but I
think art has to be enjoyed otherwise
what's the point you know
um
um otherwise it's just therapy you know
I'm just painting for therapy and we all
do things like that you know
um
has to have another human being involved
oh to me art is about a relationship
right you you can't call yourself a
romantic or somebody who chooses to to
love another if if nobody ever feels
Your Love
you know uh it's I think I think art is
um is a is is it's a type of language
right
um I know uh people who are the world's
worst communicators when it comes to
their emotions when you ask when you
have a conversation with them I've dated
some of them
um but given the opportunity to write
it's magical
and the feelings pour out on a page in
an eloquence like I've never seen and as
everyone here knows great art in some
way shape or form is always personal or
semi-autobiographical right it's too
hard to write pure fiction you know we
in we we put ourselves in it because it
gives it a sense of reality and it's
what makes us passionate for the subject
that we're tackling
um I know dancers who you know you meet
them and they're like this but as soon
as they start dancing you realize
there's it's all there so so art is
language and if no one hears you you
know does a tree if a tree falls in the
woods you know if no one hears what
you're saying is it worth saying
anything they're just thoughts
so what's the point of writing a play
that never gets shown it's just a
thought you know it's just an intention
so yeah no I think it must be shared
it's it's it's one of the ways in which
people communicate what if our why
scares us
um and and we fear that people won't see
it do we abandon it or do we just go for
it okay so there's two thoughts there
that are worth unpacking okay if other
people don't see it okay that's let's
let's deal with that first because I
think that's a little that's a little
simpler
um if other people don't see it then the
question is are we showing it right and
so many of us all of us especially at
various times
we're all lying hiding and faking at
various points right
um somebody asks a question you know
that makes us uncomfortable in a public
forum sometimes we agree to something we
say yes even though it's not true
because we just don't want to embarrass
ourselves we're very often inauthentic
plus we live in an Instagram Facebook
talkable world we're all presenting
ourselves and curating ourselves as how
we want to be so we're really good at
showing people the kind of person we
want to be it's kind of ironic as well
if you think about relationships
um you know we present ourselves as the
as our best selves but it's only really
when our vulnerabilities and
insecurities are revealed can love exist
um that's that magical authenticity so I
would argue that if if the world doesn't
see who you are you know are there ways
that you can share it with the world in
a way that is inspiring um to them and
and authentic to you
um uh how you show up you know uh
sometimes the clothes you wear sometimes
it's silly stuff
um you know I I always I would often
wear bright brightly colored ties in
college I know a little a little nerdy
but
um one because it sort of was an
reflection of my Independence I didn't
dress like everyone else but I it also
made people smile I would catch them
seeing my my tie and it would make them
smile and and I liked that
um and so there are lots of little
things we can do personally
um to bring our why to life now what I'm
really interested is what you said
Andrea when you said what if our why
scares us now if it's actually scary
because it's dangerous or difficult
um then maybe it's not fully Roi if it
scares us but because we are afraid that
others will judge us for what it is like
this is truly who I am this is why I
wake up out of bed every morning you
know then then I think you have to go
for it now the question is do you have
to jump in the deep end I think that's a
question of your own risk tolerance I
think there's nothing wrong with wading
into the water starting in the shallow
end
um I mean think about it look what I do
for a living inspire people that do the
things that Inspire them like how corny
and cheesy is that right like I'm fully
aware of that when I I first started
talking about it people were like well
that's cheesy I'm like I know I know and
so I I but I still would do it and was
it a jumping in the deep end no I would
dip my toe and I would test things out
you know and I would try things out not
see how it was received and sometimes it
went well and sometimes it didn't go
well I was learning to swim with my why
as basically was my why floaties I was
wearing y floaties that's what I was
doing
um so yeah I think if it's if you if it
feels right because that's the test of a
why you know does it feel right does it
feel like who I am does it give you
chills or Goosebumps or does it make you
well up when you think about it does it
excite you uh then it's probably
accurate and yeah then you're gonna have
to at least get in the shallow end you
dip your foot in and try try using it at
certain places and as you get more
comfortable you'll learn to swim so my
favorite definition of culture is
culture equals values plus Behavior
um and so you have to have a clear set
of values first and Innovation honesty
you know these aren't values those are
the things we write on the wall but
those are nouns and if it's values plus
Behavior it's things we want people to
do everybody thinks they're honest yet
everybody tells lies
so the value isn't be honest the value
or honesty the value is tell the truth
the value is an innovation you can't
walk into someone's office and say a
little more Innovation today please
right you know uh doesn't like nobody
you can't innovate you can't execute on
Innovation it's not an instruction
um but you can tell people look at the
problem from a different angle like
that's something you can do so to to and
by the way your values are not
aspirational they're not a bunch of
Executives sitting at an off-site
cutting pictures out of magazines and
saying this is the company we want to be
your values are who you are when you are
at your natural best
your culture already exists but you're
not necessarily always operating at your
natural best and that's as true for
companies as it is as it is for
individuals
and so to uncover your values
is not aspirational it's a process of
discovery and then you can write down
this I've never seen more than five
weirdly don't understand the biology but
when you start getting more than five
they start to overlap enough that you
could probably eliminate one of them
which I think is interesting
um but there's there's at least uh sorry
this is uh at most five values three to
five
um that are who you are when you operate
at your natural best and now the
question is is can you develop
recognition rewards incentives to
promote those values are you talking
about those values are you hiring to
those values are you firing people who
may be high performers but refuse to
live to those values because then what
you're doing is reinforcing to the rest
of the company that the values matter
more than anything else
which is really important because if we
talk about values but then all we do is
promote toxic team members who are high
performers and we've all had this happen
where sometimes even management knows
you're like you know that person is a
real [__] they're like I know but
their numbers are so good right
um and then we let them be and so that
sends a message to the rest of the
company that we're talking about these
values but we don't actually believe it
um and so you don't necessarily have to
fire the person but we do have to coach
that person I don't think you can
motivate the unmotivated I I don't think
you could motivate people people either
are motivated or unmotivated I think you
can inspire people
um and uh and you know you can motivate
people with sticks and carrots you know
offer them Bounty or threatened
punishment and you'll get behavior that
you want
is there loyalty is their love
absolutely not
um usually when people are unmotivated
it's not necessarily them it might be
the situation they're in
um maybe they don't belong in the
culture
um maybe they feel unseen or unheard
maybe they're scared maybe they're
unprepared so we we have to you know
when somebody's unmotivated let's not
label them as unmotivated first what are
the 20 other things that it could also
be let's start there now are there some
people in the world who are made
unmotivated absolutely you hired them
which means you bear some responsibility
if it's if it's time to transition them
to help them find another place where
they're going to be a better fit we
can't yell at them and call them stupid
and motivated and push them out the door
we have to bear some of the
responsibility we hired them and if we
made a mistake and hired somebody who's
a bad cultural fit then we have to take
care of them and help them transition to
somewhere where they're going to be a
better fit
um I think that um you know if we only
focus on motivating people and that's a
factor then you're only going to get
very finite thinking an excessive amount
of motivating things like hit this
number get this bonus uh you'll get a
motivated employee pool that doesn't
care about about each other might stab
each other in the back and eventually
will take a better job somewhere else we
have to inspire people we have to give
them that sense of cause and vision that
their work is worth more uh we have to
make them feel like they matter and feel
like they're seen and heard and
understood and what ends up happening is
those people are not only more vote
motivated and inspired but if they're
offered a better higher paying job
somewhere else they turn it down because
it's not just about the bonuses and the
money it's because they would rather be
here with these wonderful people so
ethical fading is a really amazing and
fascinating social phenomenon
uh basically what it is is when a group
of people make unethical decisions
believing that they have are still
consistent with their own ethical
framework in other words they don't
think they've done anything unethical
right extreme examples of this would be
things like
um a pharmaceutical company raising the
price of an essential uh uh a drug uh
500 800 a thousand percent five thousand
percent and though it may not be illegal
it's highly highly unethical
and and yet they don't think they've
done anything wrong
um uh that's an extreme example but we
see ethical fading happen all across
companies all the time
um where we do things that we know are
good for us where we might lie to our
our customers or our clients for example
or we might lie to each other to get
ourselves ahead you know this is all
these are all demonstrations of ethical
fading
um the way in which ethical fading
happens
um as you said one of the ways is just a
ridiculous unbalanced amount of pressure
on short term which forces us to think
about ourselves or or uh only think
about that short-term goal
um and then we can rationalize well
everyone's doing it it's what the
company wants me to do how else am I
going to get ahead I have to put food on
the table it's the system it's you know
like we can rationalize the behavior
um also the slippery slope we do
something a little bit once it worked we
do it a little more it works we do a
little more at work so do it and before
you know it you have full-blown ethical
fading and so the way you combat ethical
fading and and like I said I gave you an
extreme example of the Pharmaceuticals
but we see low-level ethical fading
across a lot of companies unfortunately
um and the way you combat it is uh is
one uh uh good leadership uh where that
kind of thing is not tolerated so for
example it's it's totally normal for
people to have unethical ideas
um but the question is when when do they
get caught so in an unhealthy company
that that unethical idea is implemented
until social pressure or the law
intervenes or there's a scandal right
and then we say oh we're terribly sorry
we you know we're a very good company
after you got caught in a in a in a
properly ethical company somebody May
raise the idea in a meeting
and everybody in the meeting will go
that's funny but we would never do that
here
that's that's not us that's a little bit
unethical and we get it gets shut down
immediately
um and and again that's good leadership
because it's the leaders who are
promoting people who are ethical who are
highlighting ethical behavior and acting
in a way that sets the tone and they're
not putting undue pressure on people to
break the rules in order to make the
numbers
um you know a lot of leaders
unfortunately when confronted with
toxicity or an ethical Behavior they'll
struck their shoulders and say I know
but the numbers are so good and they
allow it to happen and so one of the
primary ways in which you beat ethical
fading quite frankly is is good
leadership but the others are just cause
you know trusting teams all of these
things contribute to operating in a
highly ethical way so in the mid 1980s a
philosopher and theologian by the name
of Dr James cars articulated these two
types of games finite games and infinite
games a finite game is defined as known
players
fixed rules and an agreed upon objective
football baseball
if there's a winner necessarily there
have to be losers and there's always a
beginning middle and an end right then
you have infinite games infinite games
are defined as known and unknown players
which means you don't necessarily know
who all the players are and new players
can join whenever they want
um uh the rules are changeable which
means every player can play however they
want and the objective is to perpetuate
the game to stay in the game as long as
possible turns out we're players and
infinite games every day of our lives
right there's no such thing as
um winning global politics there's no
such thing as winning marriage you can't
be number one in your marriage you can
be number two but you can't be number
one right
um uh there's no such thing as winning
education
nobody wins learning you can come in
first for the finite amount of time
you're at school where we agree upon the
time frame and the uh uh and the metrics
grades but nobody wins education and
nobody wins business like when Circuit
City went bankrupt Best Buy didn't win
anything right
but if you listen to the language of so
many leaders half the room doesn't know
what Circuit City is I know it's sort of
I realize that it used to be a company
that competed with Best Buy same thing
Big Box store went in bought a VCR you
don't know what a VCR is right
um
what I love about this these definitions
is that when we listen to the language
of so many leaders it becomes abundantly
clear that they don't know the game
they're playing in the number of leaders
who talk about being number one being
the best or beating their competition
based on what based upon what agreed
upon metrics time frames or objectives
and this is a problem because when we
play with a finite mindset in an
infinite game when we play to win in a
game that has no finish line there's
some consistent and predictable outcomes
the big ones are the decline of trust
the decline of cooperation and the
decline of innovation so let's let's
translate that to a policing
organization right an infinite game is
not the absence of finite games it is
the context within which finite games
exist clearly you are engaged in finite
things every day of your career you have
a project that you need to complete
there's a beginning middle and end if
someone has committed a crime you want
to try and catch that person there is a
known objective there's a beginning
middle and end there's going to be a
winner there's going to be a loser right
if somebody you're chasing somebody down
for for a moving violation for example
this is these things are finite but
policing and the organization of the
Orange County sheriff is an infinite
organization we hope that this
organization outlasts everybody here and
thrives Beyond everybody here so the
decisions we make and the way we conduct
ourselves have to be considerate of the
fact that we want this organization to
thrive for the long term any participant
in any industry can get lazy
when there is little change in how that
industry operates
and then when there's a sudden change to
how the industry operates everybody gets
angry panics and points a finger
I'll give you an example
okay I'll give you two examples example
number one
taxi companies around the world hate
Uber right
now here's the reality
the app that calls a car not proprietary
you can call a taxi with it with an app
right paying with your phone
not proprietary any taxi can do that as
well
the reason Uber is eating taxi companies
for lunch is because it's a better
product
and the taxi companies around the world
could have a shitty product because
you're the only game in town and we had
no choice and now you have a competitor
and instead of competing you're getting
angry I would gladly take more cabs than
coal Services if I got in the cab and he
said hi and it was clean and I had a
nice chat with him and he wasn't on the
phone and he wasn't smoking and in all
of these things and I had some leg room
I'd glad gladly gladly has nothing to do
with the app
the pay mechanism has to do with the
fact that
Juno and Lyft are just better
is it just a better experience better
product is why I take them
it costs a dollar more whatever I'll pay
for it
it's not even a price thing I have no
idea if it's cheaper more expensive I
actually never compared
the same goes with Starbucks
right so there was a a lot of people
hate Starbucks because they put mom and
pops out of business
right the reality is the complete
opposite
that when Starbucks moves into a
neighborhood Mom and Pop's coffee shops
actually do better
for two reasons one Starbucks attract
more customers so there's just more
people and the second reason is there is
a Groundswell of giving back to the
local and so more people go to the mom
and pop right
the ones that go out of business the
ones that refuse to compete
I'll give you a real life example this
goes back a few years
a real life example I'm lactose
intolerant right so I don't have milk in
my coffee
and there was a time where
it wasn't a foregone conclusion that
every coffee shop had soy milk or almond
milk or something so I would always go
into the mom and pop that was across the
street from Starbucks always going to
the mom and pop and I'd say do you guys
have any soy milk and they go nope I go
like thank you and I would walk out
those went out of business
because I went to Starbucks he's right I
went to Starbucks
now had Starbucks moved in and they went
across the street and said let's see
what Starbucks has
we should offer soy milk maybe it's time
for us to replace this ripped couch that
we've had for 15 years because it's
really nice across there and it's really
gross here it's the ones who got angry
and refused to compete that went out of
business I think retail's the same
everybody's pointing fingers instead of
saying we've had it really good for a
bunch of years and the question is now
what is our competitor revealing about
our own weaknesses that we can
learn to improve because that's what
competition does competition reveals
your weaknesses to you and when you had
no competition you didn't know where you
were weak
this is the problem with being the best
at anything
because you don't know where your your
faults are and then somebody undermines
you because they can see your faults
before you can no one is no one is born
with self-confidence
zero
right every single one of us our
self-confidence was determined by how we
were raised the parents we had the
teachers we had the bosses we've had the
jobs we've had my sister worked for a
company for 17 years and her boss
destroyed her self-confidence she came
out of that job and she didn't realize
until she got into her new job how
afraid she was to make decisions because
of her boss and it took it took a while
for her to get her confidence back
um and so if somebody's insecure we have
to over and over and over again prove to
them
because we don't know where they came
from we don't know what kind of trouble
they got in before for being honest
right or what how they were raised we
don't know
and so we have to Total empathy and just
prove to them that that if they make a
mistake they're going to get helped not
hurt they're going to get supported not
yelled at and it the first time they
won't believe you they think it's a game
they think it's a con it's a trick the
second time maybe and we just have to
keep at it that every time I used to
have I used to have somebody on my team
who would regularly lie to me right
because she would rather lie to me than
tell me that she made a mistake
it was in and I could and if I saw the
lie I would ask so many questions to get
her to say to me I screwed up I'd be
like well this doesn't make sense
because I can't say you're lying to me
right I just say this doesn't make sense
this doesn't make sense if this adds up
to this then why is it that and she
would shoot the LIE would get bigger and
then she would yell at me about how I
don't trust her
and then at the end I have to be like
listen it clearly doesn't add up
I'm okay if it doesn't add up if you
made a mistake just tell me and I'm good
and we'll move on but when you deceive
me I'm going to ask you so many
questions to get to the truth
that it's going to get worse and worse
and worse I had to have that
conversation with her probably 50 times
before little cracks started to show
where she showed up to me once where one
number wasn't there and she looked at me
and said I made a mistake and I went
cool thanks
Alan mullaley puts it brilliantly he
says you you have a problem you are not
the problem
right so if something goes wrong we have
a problem but you are not the problem
and that's the point is we've too many
times told people that they're the
problem
so I think it's just going to take time
and patience and you have to do the hard
work of helping that person build up
their confidence again human beings we
can't help ourselves but compare
ourselves to others and comparison is is
the deadliest thing we can do to
ourselves because we will always come up
short I mean all it does is exaggerate
all of our insecurities
um it's okay to enjoy other people's
success but you let them live their
lives and you live your life oh and by
the way they're curating their social
media that's not really their life
um and so you're making decisions based
on how you feel based on their curated
things I know I've talked to so many
Millennials I know somebody who's out of
work really depressed and yet she goes
and does all these things so she has the
appearance of this amazing successful
life
and and so you met now she may be making
those decisions based on what her
friends who knows what sort of weird
Twisted exaggerated you know circle of
of depression this is forming so go back
to the rules of the infinite game your
friends are there to admire your friends
are there to say God that I'm so happy
for them what are they doing that I can
learn from I'll give you an example so
we're all we can all fall into this trap
so you know in my business uh authors
and speakers and folks like us we're all
comparing ourselves to each other and
sometimes it can get silly and
competitive and there was you know
sometimes I go on Amazon and check the
rankings of my books to see that there's
that I still have a job
and and now then there was this one
author who I hated for no reason he's
very smart his work's incredibly good
he's incredibly well respected I respect
him but I hate him
and I would check the rankings of his
books
and when I was ahead I'd be like yes
and when he was ahead I was like
weird abstract competition
same thing right social media happened
to be Amazon rankings right
and I would check in all the time I'd
always check in mine his mine his nobody
else just mine and his
anyway we were uh I was at an event and
we were interviewed together on the same
stage
and the interviewer decided to let us in
introduce each other
so I went first I had to introduce him
and this is what I said I looked at him
and I said uh you make me very insecure
I said uh because all of your strengths
are all of my weaknesses
and every time I see you do well it just
reminds me what I'm bad at
that's how I opened up
he he turned to me and he said funny I
feel the same way about you
and now we love each other
because I realized that he's really good
at what I'm bad at so by me getting to
know him and really learning to love him
I'm realizing I'm getting better at
those things
and I'm taking more pride in the things
that I'm good at rather thinking rather
than thinking I have to be good at
everything he's good at
right so that that it's it's healthy to
grow our own strengths and rather than
be intimidated by the strengths of
others the human brain cannot comprehend
the negative
it is incapable
yes it's true I'll give you an example
[Music]
okay no no I'll give you an example you
don't have to believe me
I'll prove it I'll prove it okay the
human brain cannot comprehend the
negative you ready
don't think of an elephant
uh
you can't you can't tell the human brain
not to do something right and so what
happens is we very often reinforce
things when we put things in the
negative right I can't get apart
I can't get apart
I can't get apart right or
um
um I can't do this
versus I'm going to keep doing this
I'm going to keep doing this
right
um and and it's it's such a huge thing
to convert things into the affirmative
you're supposed to do it with children
as well we're supposed to say instead of
saying to children don't eat on the
couch we're supposed to say eat at the
table
right we tell people what we want them
to do not want them what we don't want
to do pilots know this right it is well
known in the pilot community that when
you tell a pilot don't hit the obstacle
they'll hit the obstacle because what
they're doing is focusing on the
obstacle
skiers know this
if you've ever seen skiers go through
trees
do you know how they do that it's very
easy it's actually surprisingly easy if
you go through trees on skis and you go
don't hit a tree don't hit a tree don't
hit a tree guess what you're watching
you're only looking at trees
all you're doing is seeing dreams you
don't understand how anyone can ski with
all these trees
right as opposed to follow the snow
follow the path follow the path the only
thing you see is the path
skiers know this if you say don't hit a
tree you'll hit a tree you won't be able
to find a path because all you see is
millions of trees if you say only follow
the path you actually don't see any
trees there's actually very sparse trees
there's plenty of path there's plenty of
snow
it's the same thing for you if you focus
on the obstacles all you will see is
obstacles if you focus on the path
through the trees
all you will see is path through the
trees
it's your choice how you choose to
perceive your own career it's literally
perspective can you off the top of your
head can you think of you talk to you
compared you know the finite mindset to
some things with law enforcement sure as
far as infinite can you think of
anything off the top of your head where
you could relate that specifically to
what we do what that might look like
anybody who's wearing a uniform here and
knows this because you've had this
experience in your career right which is
treating someone with dignity
treating someone with dignity has
nothing to do
whether they are guilty or innocent
right
um that everybody here knows that when
you treat somebody with dignity the way
they respond to you even if they've
committed a crime and they're sitting
there in handcuffs is very very
different than when we don't treat them
with dignity so for example treating
someone with dignity may look like
somebody gets pulled over for expired
tags or something and you've they've got
a warrant I don't know and you have to
tow their car right so you call a tow
truck and now somebody who's maybe
financially struggling you've just put
at least 300 more that they have to deal
with
or treating them with dignity is like
hey I gotta I gotta tow your car before
I call a tow truck do you want to call
somebody you want to call a family
member or something who can come here
and get your car
um that'll save you 300 bucks you know
and help you out you know and if you
can't call somebody I'm gonna have to
tow it right that's treating someone
with dignity and everybody here knows
that when you treat somebody with
dignity sometimes you're taking them to
jail and they thank you
and the way in which people respond to
the uniform if treated with dignity has
nothing to do with breaking the law or
being put in handcuffs it's how it's
it's human being to human being and so I
think in a law enforcement uh when law
enforcement is conducted in the policing
organization you're thinking about the
longevity of the value of the uniform
you're thinking about the relationship
of of the the those who wear the uniform
in in public how much the public is
willing to help us if a crime is
committed and we go to the public and
say can you help us and their
willingness
those those things are determined right
now on a day-to-day basis right it and
you asked before about building of trust
right trust does there's no big thing
you can do that builds trust trust is
built up with lots and lots and lots of
tiny little innocuous little things
think of it like your own relationship
like you know have you ever been in love
the person who fell in love with you
there wasn't like I I bought you flowers
on Valentine's Day now you love me right
that's not how it works it's like you
know I went to the fridge to get myself
a drink and I got you one too without
you asking I woke up in the morning and
I said good morning to you before I
checked my phone there was a game on and
you said honey can I talk to you and I
paused the game and said what's on your
mind right I'm being idealistic I mean
um uh my point is there's no one of
those things made someone fall in love
or trust you but it's the combination
and accumulation of all those tiny
little individually innocuous things
that would say I believe you and I trust
you now imagine an entire organization
where we're just trying to do our job we
just have to enforce the law we have to
do these things these are the rules this
is how we do it but the manner in which
we conduct ourselves each one innocuous
unto itself
over the course of time builds
tremendous Trust
with an organization and the community
so that when you need to pull from that
Trust Bank when you need to make a make
a make a withdrawal right because
something's gone really horribly wrong
and maybe there was somebody who acted
illegally within the department that you
get to say to the community we screwed
up and I need your help to be patient
they go you're good
you're good but that that trust is
earned I think courage is external right
the reason someone has courage to jump
out of an airplane is because there's a
parachute on their back it's the
external thing a world famous trapeze
artist would never try a brand new
death-defying act for the first time
without a net it's the net that gives
them the courage
uh you know the Navy Seals are
considered one of the highest performing
organizations on the planet and a former
seal was asked what kind of person makes
it into the seals
and he said
I can't tell you the kind of person that
makes it in but I can tell you the kind
of person that doesn't make it
he said the Star College athletes who
have never really been tested to the
core of their being
none of them making it
he said the preening leaders who like to
delegate everything
none of them make it in
he says the guys that show up with
hulking muscles covered in tattoos
because they want to show you how tough
they are
none of them make it in
he sent it he said some of the guys who
make it in are skinny and scrawny he
said some of the guys who make it in you
see them shivering out of fear
he said but every single one of the guys
who makes it in when they're emotionally
exhausted when they're physically
exhausted when they have absolutely
nothing left to give
somehow some way they're able to dig
down deep inside themselves to find the
energy to help the guy next to them
in other words the reason these
organizations and these people have the
courage to do remarkable things is not
because of their internal strength it's
because they have the absolute
confidence that there is someone to the
left of them and someone to the right of
them that cares about them
um and they will know that and it's the
quality of the relationships that we
maintain professionally and personally
that give us the courage to do difficult
things
Isaac Stern the famous violinist said
music is what happens between the notes
well something like trust happens
between the meetings you know we a few
people think about the importance of
building trust when they go to work or
the what I need to do today to build
trust with somebody like that doesn't
really go through people's minds but we
have Chit Chat as we walk into the
meeting we've Chit Chat when we walk out
of the meeting and we see somebody the
whole they're like oh meant to tell you
something or you knock on someone's door
and be like got a minute and all those
little innocuous interactions over the
course of time like any relationship
build trust it's about setting up the
computer and setting up zoom and having
a work session with somebody you know
like we're not working on the same thing
but I want to work with somebody a work
buddy or having a lunch with somebody
over Zoom or a Monday morning huddle
where we talk about what's on our hearts
and minds but we do not talk business on
purpose or Friday uh cocktails that are
just voluntary but the most important
one is to just pick up the phone and
call people and say hey how are you
that level of empathy just check in on
someone and I think we neglect it
because we get mired in the day-to-day
but you know one of you know if you're
organized or disorganized you know
literally keep a list of your team on a
little card next to your computer and
just you know go through it and have I
called this person a while and talk to
us but I'm just going to call and check
in it doesn't matter if something's
wrong or not wrong just check in on them
you know don't wait for something to
Break
um and let people know that they're uh
that there's connection there's a way to
reach out and say I need help
um because if if if and and the most
important thing is for leaders to be
honest and open about their need to ask
for help
and that that'll work they happen to
have a coffee bar uh in the lobby of the
Four Seasons in Vegas and so one
afternoon I went and bought myself a cup
of coffee and uh the Barista working
that day was a kid named Noah
Noah was funny and charming and engaging
and I spent far too long buying a cup of
coffee because I just so enjoyed talking
to Noah so as is my nature I asked Noah
um do you like your job
and without skipping a beat Noah said I
love my job now in my line of work
that's significant like is rational I
like the people I like the I like the
work you know I get paid well I like my
job love is emotional it's a higher
order connection right like do you love
your wife I like her a lot right clearly
it's clearly a different standard right
so when Noah said I love my job my ears
perked up this kid has an emotional
connection to his work so immediately I
followed up and said tell me
specifically what the Four Seasons is
doing that you would say to me you love
your job
and again without skipping a beat Noah
said throughout the day managers will
walk past me and ask me how I'm doing
ask me if there's anything that I need
to do my job better not just my manager
any manager and then he said I also work
at another hotel
and there the managers walk past us and
catch us when we do something wrong
they're the managers are always trying
to drive performance and make sure we
hit our numbers he said there I'd like
to keep my head below the radar get
through the day and just collect my
paycheck only at the Four Seasons do I
feel I can be myself
now this is the exact same human being
working at two different companies and
yet our experience of him will be
profoundly different not because of him
but because of the leadership
environment in which he works you know I
get this question all the time you know
Simon how do we get the most out of our
people people are not a towel that you
ring them out to see how much you can
get out of them
you know it's it's a it's it's it's
that's a good one right
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a flawed question the question is
how do we create an environment on in
which our people can work at their
natural best and that is the art of
leadership it's creating environment in
which relationships can thrive in which
trust can Thrive and we all know what it
feels like to be on a trusting team
right
um it means that we feel psychologically
safe enough
to raise our hand and say
um
I made a mistake
or I need help
or I'm having trouble at home and it's
affecting my work
or I'm scared or I don't know what to do
without any fear of humiliation or
retribution but rather to say these
things with the absolute confidence that
someone on our team will rush to support
us unfortunately we also all know what
it feels like not to work on a trusting
team where admitting any of those things
could hurt your chances of promotion
could hurt your chances of it you could
be humiliated
um and so when we when we work on teams
where leadership is creating an
environment where there's where trust is
a at a premium
um we force our people to come to work
and lie hide and fake where they're
pretending that they've made no mistakes
they're lying hiding and faking and
eventually things will crack and things
will eventually break and and when you
talk about reinvention and you talk
about Innovation and you talk about
challenging the status quo or whatever
it is
necessarily there's risk and necessarily
there are mistakes and necessarily
there's stupid ideas and you have to
create an environment which that's good
the alternative is everybody playing it
safe which is not the way that leads to
to best or significant Improvement
there's no such thing as a perfect job
and there's no such thing as a perfect
person of course there are things that
we are doing that hold ourselves back
and of course there are things about the
environment in which we work whether
it's the people or the job or the
whatever the circumstances that may also
be holding us back I mean but to see
ourselves as victims is not is not the
up is not the thing but rather to seek
opportunity and it goes back to that
growth mindset
um uh which is it's what I've learned is
one of the best ways to grow oneself is
to actually help somebody on the team
grow service you know there's an entire
section in the book shop called
self-help and there's no section of the
Bookshop called help others and I think
what we've done is we've over indexed on
the whole rugged individualism sort of
self-helpy thing how can I be successful
how can I grow my business how can I
lose weight how can I find love and yet
we forget how can I help somebody else
grow their business how can I help
somebody else find success how can I
help help somebody else lose weight and
find love
Etc and the irony is is the more that we
set out to help somebody else because we
have more objectivity with other people
ironically we actually learn to help
ourselves I I tried this out I did a
little experiment
um a dear friend of mine was going
through a hard a hard time
a solopreneur
the work wasn't going well her marriage
was shaky and she was in a bad place
and so she knows what I do for a living
so she called me up and says would you
spend some time with me I said of course
so every single week religiously we
spent about 90 minutes together she'd
come over and we would talk and I would
offer some
perspective and some ideas and she'd
feel great for like a day or two and
then she'd go back and we'd get together
the next week and she'd feel great for a
couple of days and then go back in this
repeating pattern went on for quite a
while
and then I remember my own work which is
the idea of service
and had a little idea which is to switch
to switch it around and I called her up
and said look I would like some coaching
too and it was genuine I said you know
me better than anybody else I trust you
completely when we get together for one
of our sessions Can it can I can I use
up some of the time can I tell you what
I'm going through
and what ended up happening is we spent
all 90 minutes talking about my stuff
and this went week after week after week
where she was just the uh advice giver
and strange things started to happen she
started to get more stability in her
work more stability to her marriage her
confidence went up and it was because
she was helping me that she was gaining
all the insights and perspective because
it wasn't personalized it's like sales
training and anybody who's ever gone
through sales training you know this
which is you always do it with three
people you know the person who plays the
role of the salesperson the person who
plays the role of the uh the person
you're selling to the buyer and an
observer and it's the Observer that does
the learning not the people playing the
roles well in this case you got to see
herself not being not be uh so close to
it gave her objectivity so I'm a great
believer in if you have a problem to
solve at work try and help somebody else
solve that same problem I was uh during
covid
um I worked out with a friend of mine
who lives somewhere else we worked out
on FaceTime together we would just turn
on FaceTime and just do the same workout
together basically and one day we were
doing a particularly difficult workout
and I said to her I have some good news
and I have some bad news she says well
what's the bad news I said the bad news
is we're only half way done she says
well what's the good news I said the
good news is we're already halfway done
and that simple the simple way in which
I present the information literally
profoundly changes the way in which we
do the second half of the the workout
we're only halfway done the rest of the
the workout's a slog it's difficult it's
hard we don't want to do it we're
already halfway done I mean it's all
downhill we've already done this once we
can easily finish this off and it's
amazing how easy it is to change our
mindset
um uh uh and so it's the same thing here
um we've done it in our own organization
where we see another organization who
you know I mean I hate to use the word I
use it just for the for the example but
outpaces us I mean we don't care about
that but and and instead of getting all
angry and often bothered and trying to
beat them we say to them we're the
arrival what what you know what strength
do they have that's revealing a weakness
in us and we're like oh my goodness our
website sucks or our e-commerce sucks or
our you know customer service sucks or
whatever it is you know we spend a lot
of time looking at people who we admire
who are in our space who do some or many
things better than us we like look at
their websites we look at their product
we look at the ease of use we're like
wow that's really good you know we don't
have to like it we don't have to agree
with it but we can still complement it
um and I think that's the big thing
people think that you know that you you
know uh that you have to hate everything
that somebody does nonsense you don't
have to agree or like but you do have to
respect
um and uh and quite frankly to put on
blinders and go through the world with
blinders on that there's no one else out
there and they definitely can't do
anything better than you is quite
frankly just stupid because it's just
not true
um you're not great at everything and
you never will be it's an infinite game
it's a game of constant Improvement just
like every person there's no such thing
as a perfect person you know we should
be in a growth mindset constantly trying
to improve every day of Our Lives it's
the same thing and it's even that's
difficult even that's you even that you
can't you can't grow every day even
that's hard you know it's messy and
human and that's the fun and that's why
you go back to trusting teams and why
the teamwork matters so much because
sometimes we can beat up ourselves or
get stuck in a negative mindset and all
you need is one person to walk over and
be like hey worthy rival right
so the nice thing about worthy Rivals is
it's subjective you can choose whichever
person whichever company you want you
don't have internal competition but you
can have attorney work internal Rivals
you know where there are other people
that you compare yourselves to and
you're trying to get better
um uh but you don't want to stab each
other in the back get angry when
somebody else gets a promotion like
we've all had that we've all had that
you know deep down inside we see when
somebody gets a promotion when we didn't
right
um even if we weren't even up for it
um uh that's that's a that's a sign
where necessary change needs to happen
uh in our mindset uh it's easier to do
than you think and when you get in the
habit of it it's absolutely wonderful
tell someone I need help like I think it
is one of us it's one of these skills
that is becoming fast lost especially
amongst a younger generation which is
the skill to ask for help you know we're
all trying to act so tough you know this
this nation over indexed on the whole
rugged individualism thing you know
um where we define success as visual
success
and and most of our metrics most of our
incentives and almost every job are
individual incentives there you know
there's no team bonus there's an
individual bonus if you hit your numbers
you know
um and uh I think we've we've overdid it
quite frankly uh and I think it's the
pendulum needs to come back uh and and
and we have to remember that we're a
team we're members of teams we're
members of families remember communities
or members of societies and this is
where maslov got it wrong you know
Maslow's hierarchy of needs he says you
know fundamentally at the bottom of the
pyramid is food and shelter
um and he put you know third you know
third up the rung he put a a uh
relationships well I've never heard of
anyone Dying by suicide because they
were hungry I've heard of people talking
about suicide because they were lonely
so in other words it can't be right and
at the top you have self-actualization
how or like I'm all self-actualized
looking down at the rest of you who
aren't at the top of their period what
about shared actualization you know and
the mistake he made is that there's a
paradox which is every moment of every
day we are both individuals and members
of groups and every day we have to
reconcile that do I put myself first at
the expense of someone else or do I
prioritize someone else at the expense
of myself
and the answer is you're right you're
wrong and there's a whole group of
people that says no no you always take
care of yourself first because if you're
not healthy you can't help others and
there's another group of people says no
you always help others first because
unless you help them they won't be there
for you it's a paradox it doesn't work
it's not so clean
um and this is what we have to reconcile
every day and this is why finding
balance and managing it and the stresses
and trains but the the challenge of
asking for help and relying on our
community really really matters my my
definition of faith is that knowing
you're on a team even when you don't
know who all the players are
we are surrounded by people who love us
and will take care of us you just have
to ask sometimes because sometimes they
don't know that we need it
we like many
um made most of our money from in person
and Live Events and workshops and of
course that instantaneously disappeared
um and so we like many were forced to
Pivot
um and we took advantage of online
learning but we wanted to do it
consistent with our own values
um we did live classes
um because we wanted to retain some sort
of human connection as opposed to just
on-demand classes
um we called up people who we knew who
work whose work we admired and we said
you're struggling too why don't you come
and do you share your your Genius on our
platform
um and it became a very Cooperative
thing but there's a few tactics that I
learned
um to get from A to B that were really
helpful that I never would have done if
I didn't have that extreme pressure so
one of the things we did is we we shared
with the team the vision
um which we had
um and then we said to the whole team uh
we can't do this alone this is this is
literally a team effort and so what I
want is I want 15 ideas from each person
in the next 48 hours about how we can
deliver on that vision
and the team freaked out
15 ideas and 48 hours and if they wanted
to work in teams I was fine with that
um and I and and the reason for that is
um the pressure you know if I gave them
three weeks well they would have all
done the work the 48 hours before anyway
so you know uh uh so that was academic
but the important thing was the reason
for 15 ideas is because if I only ask
for two or three or three or four those
would be the same ideas I came up with
um uh and I wanted it's the idea that 11
12 and 13 that were the brilliant ones
and when we came together to report out
we did it in sort of a unique way I sort
of gave this little speech where I said
okay
um uh this is not a competition this is
about contribution
if one person has six Amazing Ideas and
you have none instead of being angry say
thank you because they just saved your
job because they had a great idea
also what I learned is that there's a
there's a difference between somebody
who has an idea and someone who's good
at executing an idea and the reality is
the most creative people in the team
that could come up with the ideas
weren't the best at executing them and
the ones that didn't have that many
ideas they were great at executing ideas
so it became really interesting and to
see who are my creators and who are my
executors from that one meeting
and we played Boggle rules if you've
ever played the game Boggle if somebody
else has your word you just skip over it
and move on I said if somebody says your
idea don't bother saying well I had that
idea too I'm not keeping score I don't
care simply move on and tell me
something else on your list and we only
let people report out two or three ideas
at a time that way we could sort of get
a flavor and what ended up happening was
people would build on the ideas that
they heard and the set of ideas that we
had at the end became our ideas nobody
could claim them anymore because we'd
all sort of tinkered with them and then
we broke them into three buckets green
yellow and red a green idea was an idea
we could execute with the money we had
and we could execute it within the week
a yellow idea was an idea that needed a
little more resource probably take a
week to a month and a red idea no matter
how good it was was too expensive or
take too long and we just parked it and
said we'll deal with those one day and
we just took all our green ideas and
executed them there are so many lessons
that we've learned over the past year
and a half to two years that I think
prepare us to be ready for the next
future
um I got a kick out of during the height
of covid uh the number of pundits who
said during these unpredictable times I
would smile and say all times are
unpredictable there's never been a time
that was predictable ever
um all that happened was something that
we didn't expect happened that reminded
us that our lives and our work is
unpredictable and to Future proof
ourselves means being ready for the
unpredictable
um there's something called an infinite
mindset and those with an infinite
mindset Embrace surprise they find
opportunity in the unexpected that when
something goes Haywire they go oh what
could we do with this versus a finite
mindset which likes to exert control and
keep things very very close and time
frame short because they fear the
uncertain they fear anything that's off
the plan and one of the things that we
have to do to Pro to Future proof
ourselves is to embrace things that are
surprises and embrace the opportunity in
uncertainty the other thing that I think
we have to learn on how to Future prove
ourselves is how to deal with stress and
how to deal with trauma
um uh whether somebody did well during
covid business this wise or whether they
struggle business-wise all of us all of
us suffered some sort of trauma and when
I when covet first showed up I called a
friend of mine who's active duty
military and I asked him during when
you're in combat what do you do to
compartmentalize your emotions so you
can stay Mission focused my business
blew up in right in front of me and I
had to focus on my mission of rebuilding
my business I wanted to know how to
control my emotions so I could get the
work done that I had to get done and he
gave me a very sobering warning he said
no one can compartmentalize their
emotions he says we can do it for a
short period of time but everyone will
suffer the trauma of combat sometimes
many months after we get home and he
said you will go through it
maybe not now but you will go through it
and uh sure sure enough about four or
five months in
um I started to feel extremely off my
game
um and uh I called him up and I said can
I just ask you you know uh what are your
symptoms when you go through the the the
trauma of combat I asked no leading
questions I simply said what are your
symptoms he said well one I fall out of
my sleep pattern for some reason I go to
bed late for no reason and I don't want
to get up in the morning and I thought
to myself
yep and he said I become unproductive
and I rationalize it like oh you've been
working hard it's okay if you have an
unproductive day or two but then I have
another and another and another and I
thought to myself yep
and he said I also become extremely
anti-social I don't want to talk to
anyone I definitely don't want to ask
for help
and I thought to myself yup
and I realized I was going through
depression I was afraid to use that word
for fear that it sounded like a
diagnosis but it was Little D depression
that's exactly what I was going through
which is why things weren't working and
so I asked my friend again so how do you
overcome it he said one you have to
force yourself to get back into your
sleep pattern and two you have to force
yourself to ask people for help
and that's exactly what I was doing and
I reached out to friends that I trusted
friends that I loved people who I knew
were dispensers of good advice and I
called them one by one and said I'm
going through this what can I do I also
reached out to friends who I knew were
going through similar things and offered
my support for them because that's one
of the things I've learned in my career
which is the best way to solve your
problems is to help people who are going
through the same thing and so to
understand how to react under extreme
stress to understand and build the
relationship so that when you do go
through something you know who to call
my rule during covet and I called all my
a-type personality friends and gave them
my rule which is there's no crying alone
and the question I would ask every one
of you is if you start to cry who are
you going to call who will you pick up
the phone and just say I need to cry and
tell them what's going on it is much
healthier to know that someone will give
you a shoulder and be there to support
you no matter what you're going through
there are many people in your industry
who talk a good game they talk about
relationships but let's be honest it's
[__] they just want to make the
transaction and move on and uh they
pretend that they care and they pretend
it's you know that they care about their
relationship when the reality is it's
one and done and on to the next and
that's what happened to me I I had a
mortgage broker uh he sold me a mortgage
he was recommended to me it's how most
of us meet somebody you know
uh uh and uh he was very nice and
charming and
was there with me and then my my sale
went through
and he called me up to congratulate me
and I was feeling a little warm and
fuzzy towards him and then
as soon as he congratulated me said and
if you could recommend me to anybody
else I'd be really grateful like
and he wasn't calling to congratulate me
he was calling to remind me to put in a
good word for him somewhere else like if
he actually cared about me and my house
then he would have just called me really
excited that I got my house and if he
wanted something from me he would have
waited a week a week or two to ask the
favor but the guy it became abundantly
clear to me I'm in the human behavior
business yes he never called me
because he cared about me yeah and by
the way I will never ever recommend him
because it was never I realized that I
was just a number on a spreadsheet and
so if you actually care about building
relationships then actually build
relationships yeah you know
um I remember when I was starting out in
my career I had a young uh a little
marketing consultancy
and I came from an industry that
pretended that they were good at
everything the marketing world like
literally they pretended they were good
at everything whether they were or
weren't and when I went out by myself
it was important to me to be honest and
clients would come and talk to me and
say we want to hire you to do all these
things and I'd say I'll do that when I'm
really good at that pretty good at that
I like doing that that I'm mediocre on
that I suck at I highly recommend you
hire another company to do that and I'm
happy to partner with them and it made
them want to do business with me more
because you said no because I told them
what I was good at what I was bad at
where I was super honest and we've all
had that experience where you want to
hire somebody and they go
you should let me introduce you to
something it happened to me recently
yeah I wanted a is it like something
silly yeah you know I needed wallpaper
yeah he highly recommended I called him
up he came he gave me a quote he's like
you know what I'm not the best at this
thing and he gave me the number of
somebody else yeah now all I want to do
is work with him again and I keep giving
out his phone number to other people
even though I actually never did work
with him yeah because what builds a
relationship is an honest broker
honesty is such a hard thing to get
especially in a transaction business
especially in a commodity business
because it is just volume and numbers
yeah and that when you actually find an
honest one all you want to do is help
them build their book of business even
though you may never do business with
them and that's what a lot of
finite-minded folks in your business
don't get yeah which is you may never
sell me a mortgage but I'll become your
biggest champion because you made it
this far in a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Alex hermosi motivation check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there they just keep going
and so to the same degree you probably
do things every single day that you
should not be doing and so what I want
to introduce to you is a concept of the
anti-routine as the most productive
routine that is humanly possible for you